Õpetaja: Aga väga nii. Ee. Screenshare läheb ka peale.
Õpetaja: Ee, päeva, teine video. Väga hea,
Õpetaja: Ee.
Õpetaja: Me tegime selle Erroriga info olukorra ära, et kui on mingi konkreetne olukord. Aga iga kord kui meil on mingi error, siis me peame arvestama, et võib tulla ka
Õpetaja: Ee, mingisuguse katastroofilise vea. Ja siis ta viskab lihtsalt viis error. Status, Code viiesaja, Et seda siin tingimustes pole ju ära niiöelda mainitud aga Ometi ta siia kukub, Sest viiesajaga samamoodi siia.
Õpetaja: Ehk Siis Siin peab alati tegema niukse else osa ka. Juurde.
Õpetaja: No mis me teeme siis, Kui midagi läheb? Katastroofiliselt. Ee, valesti, mis? Me tahame oma kasutajale, Tahame kasutajale märku anda, et midagi
Õpetaja: juhtus halvasti. On Kuidas okei jaa, No Ja Kuidas me sinna navigeerida saame?
Õpetaja: Algusel on, kus meil see on?
Õpetaja: Pole isegi seda vaja. Vaata, et meil on eraldi niiöelda kataloog
Õpetaja: Ee Navigation ja Navigation Service. Kus meil on siis erinevad navigatsioonid? Niiöelda
Õpetaja: inglise keeles Mitte nagu, noh, niimoodi saaks kogu aeg toimetada. Aga miks parema nimi on Navigation Service.
Õpetaja: Mulle nii meeldib ja siit valime.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis meetodi valime?
Õpetaja: Navigator View ja ongi kõik.
Õpetaja: Nüüd tahaks ee selle asja sisulise poolega toimetada,
Õpetaja: et ee. Praeguseks hetkeks. Meil on ära logetud isegi dünaamiliselt. Kuna me tekime selle Location Services niukse asja, et
Õpetaja: kui me Küsime Atm Location Eid. Siis meil läheb header ennast
Õpetaja: kaasa. Siia saab kommentaare kirjutada keset objekti natuke sassi. Ma ei jul julgeks seda teha. Muidugi Tahaks kirjutada, et kustuta ära kui pole enam Stoplight I vaja. Aga võibolla selle. Too Ga Hoiab meeles.
Õpetaja: Ee et me praegu ütleme, et Kui meil City on null, siis anna eksamel null. Kui kaks, siis kolm ja nii edasi. Kõikidel teistel juhtudel, anna meile, seda et ei leidnud. Ehk siis Tartuga. Saame selle probleemi, et. Ee, et justkui vastab. Vaata, et kuule. Nelisada, neli ja error kaks, kaks,
Õpetaja: nii aga Nüüd on siis vaja et Okei, need andmed tuuakse ära.
Õpetaja: Ainuke asi, kuidas me praegu üldse midagi näeme, Ongi lihtsalt see. Vot siin on Nüüd see olukord. Vaata, mis ma rääkisin. Ee, kui meil tekib mingi nupu vajutusega mingi alert.
Õpetaja: Aga ainult selles error olukorras muudetakse error message i sisu.
Õpetaja: Okei, sain oma. Noh, teeme niimoodi uuesti. Ma teen refresh Iga
Õpetaja: mis on pugi, on see, et kujutame ette, et tulid Tallinn, Asjad tulid Tartu asjad
Õpetaja: Pärnuga ei tule. Ühtegi asja. Tuleb see teade. Okei, aga kasuta nüüd kliki nagu tallinna peale. Siis
Õpetaja: mis nüüd siis Selle Erroriga on?
Õpetaja: Ei lähe ära, sest et programmiliselt on ainult üks koht alguses. Ta saab tühja väärtuse error message ja kui on viga, Siis ta saab uue sisu, Aga ta kunagi enam rohkem ei muutu.
Õpetaja: No siin on see lihtne trikk, et lihtsalt iga Jumala kord,
Õpetaja: kui Me hakkame saatma. Ee, mingisugust sõnumit. Näiteks see Get Locations,
Õpetaja: mis käivitub selle selle peale. Vaata, kui me panime, kus ma oli, kus see Uus meetod oli, mis me tegime.
Õpetaja: Kus see meetod kadus nüüd see on? See
Õpetaja: gets. Selected City. Locations, mäletate? See käivitub kui alt, tuleb sõnumist.
Õpetaja: Nii põhimõtteliselt, siis me teame, et iga kord kui me hakkame tooma, ära uusi asukohti siis Esialgu peaks
Õpetaja: reset ima selle esimese tegevusena me Peame resetima. Ära err message sisu. Algseis on niimoodi. Pole probleemi.
Õpetaja: Siis kas tuleb ette või ei Tule, Tuleb siin teha.
Õpetaja: Noh, kuidas me seda teeme.
Õpetaja: Meetodiga. Lõpptulemus on see, et mille pealt niiöelda seda alert message It niiöelda kuvatakse,
Õpetaja: kui see olemas on, aga mis mis Essee on
Õpetaja: error. Message.
Õpetaja: See meie muutuja, mis on mõeldud teenendama seda alert. Message It on ju?
Õpetaja: Ehk siis kui mina annan talle täiesti Iga kord, kui tuuakse neid location eid ära, siis algseis on see, et ei ole
Õpetaja: error ilt ja siis kui käivitatakse Gat Locations, no Siis selgub,
Õpetaja: kas kukutakse siia errorisse ja on vaja jälle ikkagi näidata. Valgseis on siis puhas.
Õpetaja: Ehk siis proovime tallinn Pärnu Tallinn, saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Te peate nagu. Noh, see jääb niikuinii testimisel silma lõpuks. Vaata, et sa teed proovid erinevaid asju ja vaatad, Oota, aga see
Õpetaja: mingi Asi tuli nähtavale ja peaks peitu minema. Aga kogemusest tegelikult juba teaks.
Õpetaja: Kui mingisugune error kuskil midagi toob ette nähtavale, siis on alati vaja Mõelda sellele, et. Aga siis see tähendab, et me peame. Noh, kui see mingi nuppude vajutuse peale toimub, et iga kord, kui uuesti nuppu vajutad, siis me lähtestame selle seisu. Vaata, et ei ole viga.
Õpetaja: Et kui Cloud Coat tegi mulle ka koodi, Vaata, ma ei pidanud talle seda kuidagi ette ütlema. Nagu oma projektis, Onju, et. Oo, käitu niimoodi. Mul oli. Ära öeldud, et tuleb Niuke error.
Õpetaja: Siis Tema mõtles ka Kohe seda, et. Aga et kui see tegevus käivitub, kus võib tulla error, siis on vaja alati kõigepealt taastada algseis reset. Vaata,
Õpetaja: et ee, See on Niukene
Õpetaja: kogemusega juba teada ära, et et juba siit programmi seda koodi kirjutades. Tegelikult, Aa, kui. Kui oleks juba olnud see muutuja olemas. Meil lihtsalt polnud teda veel. Aa, kui oleks olnud see muutuja olemas,
Õpetaja: siis oleks selle saanud sinna teha. Tegelikult on isegi parem koht, kus seda teha. Me panime niimoodi. Vaata, et Aa Get Locations. Ainult kui see
Õpetaja: ainult sellel hetkel vaata, resetitakse see ära. Tegelt on isegi Parem üks parem koht, kuhu selle võiks panna, kuhu
Õpetaja: ja
Õpetaja: perfekt? Et me kutsume selle meetodi välja. Nüüd ei ole vahet, kus me seda kutsume, siis on niimoodi, et kui me paneme siia sisse selle.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd on Ju garanteeritud.
Õpetaja: Vahet pole, esimesel korral see käivitatakse ee, kui Komponent laetakse. Error messil ongi tühi, et sa kirjutad tühja tühja küla, aga see ei maksa meile tõesti midagi. Pigem on meil see, et Meil on kindel toimiv süsteem et iga kord, kui tuuakse Location Id ära, Sest et siin see error saab juhtuda,
Õpetaja: siin saab juhtuda. Näed, Kuigi tuleb mingi error ja on see tingimus
Õpetaja: nüüd on nii
Õpetaja: Meil on teisi variante ka. Vaata, et me ei pea alati teid ära navigeerima ka, kui kui me tingimata seda. Me võiksime tegelikult siia ka teha Vaata, nagu A. See ei ole nii äge. Muidugi, error Message Isse võiks panna sama hästi ka, et
Õpetaja: ma näitan. Ma ei tee niimoodi Ups,
Õpetaja: midagi läheks valesti. Lihtsalt et te teate, et, noh, ka Niukse lähenemise võib võtta selle. Kommenteerime korra välja,
Õpetaja: et see vahe on siis See on ju, et,
Õpetaja: noh, vale sõnum läks nüüd, kui see ongi õige. Sorry, Aa, ma ei saa. Viite sada tekitada, Kurat võtaks.
Õpetaja: Tahaks mõelda mingit nigu. Lihtsalt, ee, moodust. Kuidas saaks kuidagi lihtsalt viitesada ka tekitada.
Õpetaja: Ma ei viitsi sellega tegeleda. Ee, ma lihtsalt kain Ja panen siis korra. Võibolla selle hoopis siia. Sisse. Lihtsalt kommenteerin selle välja, et kujutame ette, et kui läheb, mina, valin ee, lehte laengi
Õpetaja: Ja vaata, see on vale koht.
Õpetaja: Mõtle, kui tüütu on niukest asja teha,
Õpetaja: Kujutame ette, et laen seda lehte. Vaata, see teade võib ka sellisel kujul tulla. Mis tahes hetkel
Õpetaja: ei ole nagu ei ole nagu nõutud,
Õpetaja: Aga lihtsalt see vahe ongi see, et. Kas sa vaata, siis ongi see, et sa pead hästi natuke mõtlema. Kuidas nad asjad siia jäävad Ja nii edasi arenduse käigus. Selline variant oleks parem, kui mul on mingid säted asjad. Kas mingid kastid on täidetud? Mida iganes, et kui Midagi Katastroofiliselt läheb Backendis sassi. Siis ta viib meid alati. Error vaatajale. Ma ei saagi aru. Vaata, mis
Õpetaja: ma ma enam ei saa taastada seda olukorda, et mis ennem oli? Vaata Mingid vormid olid täidetud ja nii edasi, Onju
Õpetaja: siis? Sellises olukorras oli isegi mõnusam et sul on Mingid asjad täidetud. Ta ütleb, et midagi läks valesti,
Õpetaja: aga. Noh, ma mõtlen, et pigem tehakse ikkagi selle jaoks Niukene.
Õpetaja: Mingi selline asi, tehakse Pigem jälle valikute. Küsimus, et. Ee. Need on nagu teie tööriistad.
Õpetaja: Ei, ma taastan selle. Mis siin oli?
Õpetaja: Ahaa, lihtsalt teadmine. Kui teil läheb midagi kaduma. Ta Juba mingisuguseid muudatusi, mis on nagu Kit i mõttes kadunud. Tsau,
Õpetaja: teil on alati ka Niukene asi Nagu parem klõps ja Lokalist oli Show History.
Õpetaja: See nüüd intellige ja ise. Trackib ka kõike meie koodi muudatusi. Kui ma sa teed selle faili peale, siis ta näitab siin failis. Vaata, ta näitab, et hetkel on seis siukene.
Õpetaja: Natukene aega tagasi oli Niukene. Saate siin vaadata neid muudatusi, et kuidas ennem oli Teil on mingisugune ajalugu. Vahel juhtub seda, et kogemata läheb prügikasti. Mingi muudatus,
Õpetaja: Muudatused.
Õpetaja: Kui te vajutate kuskile kataloogi peale, siis oleneb siis. Ta vaatab kõiki neid faile, mis nendes alamkataloogides on olnud, kui ta siia näiteks klõpsi ajada. Local History Show History.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta hakkab failide järgi vaatama, Nagu mul ei ole siin praegult mingeid faile väga. Aga saate mõttest aru. Teil on võimalik igasuguseid muudatusi
Õpetaja: vaadata.
Õpetaja: Tagantjärgi, Kuidas Ee, Ma See mälu ulatub väga kaugele. Ma ei. Ma ei tea, kui kaua, kui hoiab meeles endale asju, sest see ei ole enam kit,
Õpetaja: Vaid see on nüüd nagu sisse ehitatud funktsionaalsus.
Õpetaja: Ee, seda ongi hea kasutada siis, kui läheb midagi totaalselt kaduma vahel ja sa tead, et sul see mingi hetk tagasi oli? Ja enam Kit I komiteedesse. Sa ei teinud mingit komite. Noh, et see alati on ju võimalus lihtsalt Otsida neid komite, onju, et kus sa nagu midagi tegid,
Õpetaja: on ju? Ja minna nendesse kohtadesse tagasi kõrval ju näitama neid faili muudatusi, Igasuguseid võimalusi on. Aga kui sa ei ole teinud neid muudatusi, siis ei tähenda seda, et sul ei ole võimalik midagi taastada
Õpetaja: ühtteist. Tal on ikka võimalik taastada ka.
Õpetaja: Nii Okei, ee. Meie saame need andmed kätte. Sellest City Stop Town Ist paneme. Selle üldse kinni
Õpetaja: ee. Selle, alerdi Võime ka kinni panna.
Õpetaja: Tähendab, ee, Alerdi. Teeme lahti, aga otsime.
Õpetaja: Ei, selle roo. Paneme kinni ja alumise. Roo, teeme lahti, aga võime kolumnile ka kinni panna. Me nüüd keskendume sellele tabelile.
Õpetaja: Ee, kas praegult on siin kasutatud ühtegi muutujat?
Õpetaja: Tatabloki Muutujat Ei ole, aga kui oleks ja Me teeksime sellest eraldi klotsi. Siis see läheb Propsiga kaasa, Sest et me viitame asjadele infole, mis asub kuskil Noh, siin. Näiteks
Õpetaja: siis. See Peab sinna ju alla Flowma see dataabloki Sisu Saame meie manipuleerida, Muuta Propsi mitte kunagi.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, väga tore.
Õpetaja: Mis me. Mis on see Ma ütlen nüüd vihjeks ära, et ee. Soovimegi kasutada seda Locations objekti.
Õpetaja: See on massiiv. Ütleme selle esimese objekti Siit kokku. See on massiivelementidest,
Õpetaja: Mis me tahame sellega nüüd teha?
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted teil on?
Õpetaja: Need andmed siin peavad tulema vastavalt sellele massiivile, mis me tahame teha, Mis tööriist on?
Õpetaja: Mis on see võte millega, me nüüd tahame? Vastavalt sisule kuvada ridu.
Õpetaja: Mis on V fooriga meie esimene ülesanne. Meil on vaja aru, saada, et kuhu? Elemendi? Mis elemendi? Tag I sisse. Me peame seda kirjutama. Mina küsin teilt minu vaatest. Mis reale? Mis tag I? Me Tahame kirjutada V Foori sisse.
Õpetaja: Kakskümmend kaheksa. On see rida? Mis asi see T idee on?
Õpetaja: Ei, ole tabel. See on veerg.
Õpetaja: Tabel on meil siin.
Õpetaja: No hakkame võtma lahti. Nüüd ma võtan korra Body kinni. Siin on veel nagu eraldi tag Id, mida me ise oma variandis õppinud. See on table. Head ja esimene table. Row. Kus on need Veeru nimed? Linnasukoht. Teenused. Olete nõus?
Õpetaja: Seda ei soovi teha. Vist tuhat korda, on ju
Õpetaja: muidu tuleb Mingi niuke. Asi ei soovi vale.
Õpetaja: Nii Nüüd ma toon korra selle Table Bodies. Niiöelda pakuti. Kakskümmend kaheksa. No Kui ma teeksin seda. Kakskümmend kaheksat siin. Näiteks Viis korda.
Õpetaja: Siis vist ei ole ka. Me ei taha Veerge juurde teha Ei taha jah, Mida me tahame juurde teha,
Õpetaja: kui siin on Captable Body. Kas tahame seda teha juurde?
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kuidas see, isegi. Välja näeks, sa Ei näekski.
Õpetaja: Seda. Ei taha mitut teha. Mida me tahame teha. Mitmeid
Õpetaja: Kolmkümmend üks, kolmkümmend, Üks sularaha. Siis sai välja, vä.
Õpetaja: Mis asi, Jah, Table Row Mitu rauda on Hetkel üks? Kas äkki neid tahaks teha juurde, Onju Siis
Õpetaja: See ongi see element, mis peab dünaamiliselt tulema nii Mitu korda meie nägu jälle paneme? Ainult ühe rea paika. Tema teeb siis vastavalt. Kui Massiivis on null elementi, siis ta ei tee ühtegi rida.
Õpetaja: Kui seal on kolm elementi, siis ta teeb kolm rida.
Õpetaja: See. On
Õpetaja: see korduv osa. Mõelge justkui niimoodi. Tehke siniseks, mida peab tulema uuesti ja uuesti uuesti. Ja otsige tema kõige välimine
Õpetaja: element ülesse.
Õpetaja: Ever Row.
Õpetaja: No mis ma siia kirjutan? Vii Four
Õpetaja: Nüüd siin. On see niukese. Äh, ma juba tahtsin peaaegu ette öelda. Või ütlengi võibolla. Mis on see hästi lihtne mall, millest alustada
Õpetaja: see on hästi lihtne süntaks Ja Siis ma ütlesin vih. Vihjeks on, et küsimärk.
Õpetaja: Küsimärk, in, küsimärk.
Õpetaja: Käi läbi. See kollektsioon ükshaaval paremal pool peab olema mingisugune kollektsioon, mis on Meie kollektsioon
Õpetaja: Locations. Me oleme tag I sees atribuudi sees. Me saame otse viidata. Lihtsalt Locations. Ei ole mingit. Ee, Ei ole. Vaja Mingit Aa loogilisi sulgusid Ei ole. Vaja seda koolonit. Me oleme niiöelda tag i atribuudi Sees. Atribuudi sees saab otse viidata
Õpetaja: vaadake niiöelda niimoodi et Te teete ühe tõksu. Teete niimoodi, kui see sõna on. Noh, Cities ei saanud nagu seda teha, aga Locations saab teha, mis on Nagu Siis see üksikobjekt sellest. Noh, te olete sellest essist mööda. Hoiate shift I peal ja tulete niimoodi kopi
Õpetaja: tuletada ette selle siniseks kontroll V Ja ongi olemas. Mis asi see siin on? Ma küsin, mis asi on?
Õpetaja: Mis asi on?
Õpetaja: Mis asi see Location on?
Õpetaja: Ma räägin Nüüd süntaksist Konkreetselt. Mis asi see on?
Õpetaja: Vist tuli vastus. Ma ei kuulnud kindlalt, mis asi on?
Õpetaja: See on sildikene. Vaadake, see on sildikene, Mis on tatablokis
Õpetaja: Siin taga. On massiivi objekt. Siin on andmed.
Õpetaja: See Nüüd on uus sildikene.
Õpetaja: Selle sildi taga hakkab igal tsüklil olema üks Objekt niimoodi dünaamiliselt.
Õpetaja: Kõigepealt võetakse esimene objekt, teine objekt ja nii edasi. See on meie sildikene. Pange tähele Ta on ainsuses
Õpetaja: nüüd väiksed nõuded Punane joon on Siin all. Vanasti ta isegi punast joont alla ei tõmmanud. Midagi Ta vingub Miski Talle ei meeldi.
Õpetaja: Sulle ei meeldi, vaata, Mis ta jääb. Ib
Õpetaja: eesliit annab märku. See on üks asi, mis on ka projektis juures. Vaatame Package. Jason,
Õpetaja: näete seda ees? Linti?
Õpetaja: See on lõppkoodis. Pole eeslint es linti vaja. Aga praegult on vaja linter. Tema käib meie koodi üle ja informeerib, kui midagi ei meeldi ja Ta mängib meiega kokku see teade siit on Eslinterit.
Õpetaja: Es on mingi tehnoloogia? Ma Täpselt, ei tea, mis on igal juhul see on mingi Standard
Õpetaja: Elements of iteration expect to have key
Õpetaja: for ee requir we four key.
Õpetaja: Ta vajab võtit. Kas te mäletate, mis asi see võti oli Siin kontekstis,
Õpetaja: Mille jaoks on võtit vaja? Siin number. Keskus.
Õpetaja: Aitäh.
Õpetaja: Kuidas
Õpetaja: See on see väärtus, mis me sinna tahame, aga rääkige mulle, Milleks on see vajalik oma sõnadega? Miks on vaja talle anda nagu tsüklis ette mingisugune võti?
Õpetaja: Võti, mis tegelikult kehtib siis iga objekti kohta, Mis seal? Aa, mis selles niiöelda massiivis on? Sest et Eu foori saab teha ainult massiiviga on ju objektiga Ei saa. Ju tsükeldada
Õpetaja: lihtsalt Üksikobjektiga
Õpetaja: järjestus on midagi muud. Andmed tulevad back endist nii, nagu andmed tulevad Jasonis. Siis nii on. Jah, Me Saame siin Jalascriptiga järjekorda muuta, kui vaja.
Õpetaja: Aga see ei ole see, mis ma otsin.
Õpetaja: Miks meil on vaja giid anda? Et.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on.
Õpetaja: Ongi. Ongi uuendada.
Õpetaja: No, Kes on osa sellest? Vaata, näed aga enne seda, mis ma olen teile rääkinud
Õpetaja: Tommi uuendada. Ta saab ilma selle kiita ka tegelikult hakkama. Ma ütlen väga edukalt. Noh, tegelikult väga edukalt ongi see küsimärk Pigem
Õpetaja: ta saaks midagi
Õpetaja: lihtsalt võrrelda. Jah, täpselt. Henrik, näed midagi? On, Ee, Keegi ikka midagi teab ka? Ee, väga hea.
Õpetaja: Teab, et ta saaks midagi lihtsalt võrrelda Point on see, et meil on reaktiivne muutuja see Locations.
Õpetaja: Selle Sisu saab muutuda. Voe arvestab sellega ja voe nüüd igal pool Nende reaktiivsete muutujatega peab jälgima seda, et kas on toimunud muutus Selle sisus.
Õpetaja: Kui on sisus toimunud muutus, siis tuleb Html kood uuesti genereerida. Noh, meie mõtleme, et see osa tuleb uuesti joonistada. Mingi osa Veebilehest tuleb uuesti joonistada andmete peal
Õpetaja: ja tal on lihtsalt natukene raske vaadata. Ee, neid objekte tervikuna. Kui Meie objekt ongi selline nagu siin. Selles task is ka on,
Õpetaja: Kui meie objekt on selline.
Õpetaja: See on üks objekt. See on järgmine objekt. Vaadake seda, Kui palju on siin informatsiooni.
Õpetaja: Ta võib hakata tegema vigu, kus ta ei märka mingisuguseid väikseid nüansse, mis on muutunud taustal midagi taolist. Mingi kuidas taas tuleb välja Vanasti, kui seda eest internetti, ei olnud mul projekti juures, siis seal punast joont alla ei tulnud
Õpetaja: ja siis oli endal vaja meeles hoida, et kui sa teed ee fooriga tsüklit, siis pane alati siis kippus veits ununema. Nüüd on natuke raskem. Vaata, punane Joon, nagu tõmbab tähelepanu Ja ütleb, et midagi on halvasti.
Õpetaja: Ja siis oligi niimoodi, et keegi, tegi oma mingit tööd. Eriti kui tal oli alamkomponendid ja mingid asjad Ja mingi hetk ikka et keegi tuli. Ütles, et Kurat, see nagu asi ei tööta nagu korrektselt, et vahel ta nagu renderdab muudatust, vaata Vajutad nuppu ja peab muutuma. Vahel ei muutu, on ju? Siis oli? Pea. Alati oli niimoodi. Vaata, et, ee, Kui tegemist oli voortsükliga, siis oli niimoodi, et,
Õpetaja: ee. Kui tal giid juures ei olnud, siis ta ei märkand kuidagi muudatusi. Ta ei saanud hästi aru
Õpetaja: ja niipea kui Andsid talle ette ühe numbrilise väärtuse, mida ta peab jälgima Nagu Näha erinevusi. Siis ta sai kohe hakkama. Panid Ghee juurde. Kõik Töötas nagu Nõia väel
Õpetaja: ei tulnud enam mingisugust imelikke anomaaliaid See on see mõte, et
Õpetaja: see mõte ongi nüüd. Nüüd on nagu parem vaadata.
Õpetaja: Meie ise Ütleme talle ette. Vaata, et tead siin voortsüklis igat objekti. Kui sa läbi käid, siis Sina lihtsalt jälgi neid väärtusi.
Õpetaja: Nii, ja hoia meeles, Mis sul on
Õpetaja: nüüd? Kui mingi hetk sa järsku andmetes toimub muudatus, siis ta jälgib nagu neid numbreid. Kui need numbrid nüüd järsku muutuvad Siis Ta teab, et me oleme ise ette talle öelnud. Nüüd on vaja uuesti rendeldada,
Õpetaja: Sest et kui see number muutub, on meie soov, et muutuks ka sisu. Kui tuleb üks number juurde,
Õpetaja: siis on üks number juurde tulnud. Järelikult ta peab uuesti joonistama. Kui on üks number vähem, siis ta peab seda uuesti tegema. Kui üks nendest numbritest muutub järjekord näiteks, siis ta peab uuesti joonistama.
Õpetaja: Ta vaatab neid numbreid, Ta vaatab järjestust,
Õpetaja: aga ta ei pea vaatama enam tervet objekti.
Õpetaja: Ta peab ainult vaatama neid numbreid. Ja see ongi see Ghee, Me tahame öelda, et sina käi läbi iga objekt iga objekti juures. Vaata mingisugust unikaalset asja. Soovitavalt, mis on ideaalselt Id.
Õpetaja: Vaata neid numbreid need ei kordu, Sest et. Jama oleks Vaata see, kui see ei oleks unikaalne.
Õpetaja: Ütleme niimoodi, et oletame näiteks, et. Ee. Me vaataksime. Location Name I
Õpetaja: Siin On üks sikupilli Prisma Ja siin on üks teine sikupilli. Prisma. Oletame, et nad tegelikult on ikkagi erinevad. Üks on tallinnas, teine on Tartus, Ma ei tea, miks, näiteks
Õpetaja: kui te vaataks niukest asja. Need kaks tükki vahetavad omavahel lihtsalt asukohad,
Õpetaja: siis tema jaoks ei ole mitte midagi muutunud.
Õpetaja: Sest kui me oleme, ütleme, et jälgi seda. Vaata, et, noh, ennem oli sikupilli. Prisma, sikupilli, prisma ja jõeprisma. Nüüd on sikupilli prisma, sikupilli prisma jõeprisma,
Õpetaja: et tegelikult me nagu anname talle nagu ette nagu ise. Vaata, mida ta peab jälgima Ja meile ideaalis on ikkagi midagi, Mis on unikaalne. Ja kuna me kasutame relatsioonilist andmebaasi ja enam meil on neid numbreid tegelt pärast vaja. Ka meil on neid numbreid vaja. Me ei pea neid kuvama kasutajale.
Õpetaja: Me ise otsustame, mida me kuvame üldse. Jason, ist automaatselt. Seda Jason It ei kuvata iga asja, mida Me tahame, et kuvatakse. Me peame ise programmeerima. Me peame vaeva nägema,
Õpetaja: et midagi kuvatakse ja täpselt. Ütleme, mida kuvama peab
Õpetaja: et me, ei Pea neid kuvama. Aga meil tegelikult neid numbreid läheb ka hiljem vaja. Jumal tänatud on seal olemas. Aga isegi kui oleks neid vaja, siis Kui hea on anda talle ette midagi, et ta vähemalt ridade mõttes oskab väga täpselt jälgida. Kas midagi muutub,
Õpetaja: eks? Me saame kiita. Tegelikult Me saame nime teistmoodi teha. Me saame tegelikult väärtusi ka kokku panna. Me saame tegelikult öelda, et ära vaata lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd me saaksime talle öelda, kui me tahaks, et. Vaata, näiteks Location Name I
Õpetaja: ja Citynam I. Pane nad lihtsalt kokku. Noh, ma korraks nagu paneks, et tahaks seda siia muuta, Aga ma tahaksida selle siia nagu.
Õpetaja: Vaata niukest ringi.
Õpetaja: Me ise ütleme Vaata kaks välja. Liida omavahel. Keevita kokku, jälgi neid, Noh, Siis oleks sikupilleprisma Tallinn ja sikupilleprisma. Tartu, Vaata, me saame ka niimoodi teha kui meil ei ole mingit unikaalset asja nagu Id D,
Õpetaja: Aga mis me näeme? Nagu, et tervikuna moodustavad unikaalsuse, midagi, mida tema jälgib. Ja siis ta nagu näeks. Vaata et kui sikupiiri prisma tallinn Ja on sikupiiriprisma. Tartu, vaata. Ja järsku see järjekord on teistpidi. No siis ta teab, et ta peab uuesti renderdama. Meie mõte on endiselt, See, et meil on lihtsalt vaja. Nagu teda nagu juhendada
Õpetaja: Nii, nüüd ongi see, et igal tsüklil juba praegu see töötab juba, Kui ma Tulen, Ee, lähme veebilehele. Vaata, siis ta juba on. On kolm asja sisu. Lihtsalt on Fix Tallinn Prisma sularaha. Prisma. Kõik see, mis siin on? Kas siin oli mingit võtit vaja?
Õpetaja: Ei olnud Ju töötab. Proovime, paneme Tartu, paneme pärnu,
Õpetaja: paneme tallinn. No Sisu On kogu aeg üks Sama Me pole midagi teinud. Ridade arv muutub. Kas tal on võti olemas?
Õpetaja: Ei ole, Ta tegelikult saab hakkama, aga see ei Ole väga.
Õpetaja: Parem või hiljem, tule meie jama.
Õpetaja: No meie ütleme, et iga rea peale. Vaata sina konkreetse location i location Id.
Õpetaja: Nii, esiteks, nüüd on Siis vaja siia atribuuti.
Õpetaja: Ghee,
Õpetaja: mis ma nüüd siia kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Mis on Okei Kirjutan Location I idee või
Õpetaja: ei?
Õpetaja: Miks see ei sobi? Igaühe Võti on Mis asi? Kõik kolme? Rea võti. Üks sama võti on lihtsalt String Location Id.
Õpetaja: Ma ütlen, et praegult kolm rida, mis siin on on ju? Nendel Kõigil on võti taustal Location Id.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et hetkel, mis värvid on
Õpetaja: roheline, Kuidas, Mis värvi meie muutujad on?
Õpetaja: Noh, Valged või lillad. Üldjuhul midagi on puudu.
Õpetaja: Mis on koolon? Nüüd Edaspidi ma ei viitsi seda lõputult seda jahuda. Vaata, aga lihtsalt te ise Muidugi näeksite, kui me hakkamegi mingist muutujast mingile atribuudil mingit sisu andma. Kas klass või mis iganes Dünaamiliselt tuleb, paneme kohe kooloni
Õpetaja: Näe, nüüd, Juba valitsed selle, Key.
Õpetaja: Ma panen võrdusmärgi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ta pakub. Mis on nüüd suur viga? Mis ma võiks praegult teha?
Õpetaja: Suur viga võiks olla See, et ma panen Locations siia, mis nüüd valesti läks
Õpetaja: ja ei saa ka panna seda, mida ee pakkus enne Riho lihtsalt Location Id
Õpetaja: Selle kohta. Ta ütleb, et niukest muutujat ei ole küll kusagil nagu Location Id.
Õpetaja: Ja ma viitan kõigepealt sellele sildile, sest et siin taga on üks objekt
Õpetaja: selle Location I sees ongi tervelt üks objekt.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: kui ma tulen. Aa, kus mul see taas kolin sees esimesel tsüklil, Mis tema automaatselt teeb, On selline objekt.
Õpetaja: Aga kui mina tahan nüüd viidata näiteks Location Id Le, siis ma pean viitama kõigepealt sellele objektile, Ma saan seda teha ainult läbi selle sildi. Ju Ma ütlen, et võta Location objekt ja sealt Location Id.
Õpetaja: Ja kui me nüüd hakkan seda siin kirjutama. Siis näeme, et asi on nagu veits teistsugune kohe.
Õpetaja: Aga see on klassikaline viga, et kogemata saad. Vali, valid mitmuses, ja Siis te juba meelevaldselt teete mingit niukest asja.
Õpetaja: See ei tööta. Sa viitad massiivile?
Õpetaja: Massiivil ei ole välju. Esiteks, massiivil on elemendid, millel saab ligi indeksitega.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see asi. Vaata, et kui sa viitad Location I, näete, kuidas läheb Valgele? Kohe läheb särama. Siin
Õpetaja: nüüd on hall.
Õpetaja: Aa, sa viitad sellele sildile et saada sealt selle sildide alam alamväljale ligi punkt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Ta pakub neid samu asju, mis meil on, mudelis Defineeritud.
Õpetaja: No mis mind huvitab siit sellest, et oleks
Õpetaja: jah. Niipea, kui te ei kirjutate, ja ei paku midagi ennem, kui kui tahaks seda sama kama kirjutada kokku. Vaata, siis läheb päris pikaks. Ei saagi, Tab i valida.
Õpetaja: Mis viga oli õige.
Õpetaja: Siin on. Aa oot oot, oot, Oot, oot, oot, pole seda Ja Ja et atribuut võtab sisse lihtsalt ringa väärtuse. Mõtlen seda reklaam muutujast.
Õpetaja: Kirjutan Locations panen punkt, mis ta ei paku omale location Id
Õpetaja: No ta tegelikult oskab. Lõpuks hakkab pakkuma ka. Aga vaata, sest. Aga see ei ole enam see
Õpetaja: tegelikult on See vale.
Õpetaja: Kui ta kohe ei paku, siis on midagi. Kui ta punkti peale juba ei paku sulle midagi normaalset asja. Vaadake, paneme punkti, kohe pakub.
Õpetaja: See on nagu kohe peaks olema Trigger. Oot, oot, oot, oot. Midagi on valesti. Midagi On valesti.
Õpetaja: Location Id. Nüüd on see võti olemas. Nüüd ta töötab perfektselt.
Õpetaja: Senikaua kuni see on, mille järgi me asju eristame Ja nii ongi. Noh, pluss siit ongi siis nagu,
Õpetaja: Okei, Smidi.
Õpetaja: Ei, siin ei ole enam uut silti silte. On Meil praegult ainult kaks.
Õpetaja: Tähendab, silte on meil. Ma näitan sildid, kõik sildid, Mis on datablokis? Need on sildid. Üks, kaks, kolm, neli, viis.
Õpetaja: Need on sildid, mis meil siin skoobis on? Kättesaadavad mistahes elemendis on kättesaadavad. Aga see süntoksiin
Õpetaja: teeb uue sildi siia paremale ja avas täpselt samamoodi. See on meie viies või kuues silt. Mul läks juba lugemine sassi
Õpetaja: Seda me saame nüüd kasutada. Seda pead ise nüüd mõtlema, et dünaamiliselt ta käib kolm korda läbi.
Õpetaja: Kolm korda teeb seda. Ee, iga kord Ta võtab Location Ist ja paneb ühe niiöelda rea kiiks. Paneb Location Id väärtuse üksteist. Kaksteist, kolmteist, Mis iganes. Numbrid tulevad
Õpetaja: nii praegult, nüüd On nagu see asi, et hetkel ta teeb täpi pealt seda, mis talle, on ette öeldud. String, string string, string, string string, string. Et Tee üks uus Table Ro element, Siis see läheb väärtus, Tallinn.
Õpetaja: Aga me ei taha. Tallinn et oleks, sisse kirjutatud. Mida meie tahame,
Õpetaja: City Name. No ku. Kuidas ma kirjutan? Ütle mulle, mis ma kirjutan.
Õpetaja: Ee, ütleb, mis ma kirjutab. Kõik see on.
Õpetaja: No ma kirjutan Location No Ja nüüd juba tuli. Ära vaata, aga ma tahtsin näidata seda et kui ma hakkan kirjutama Location It, siis mul on ka see, et Miks ma pean selle sõna välja kirjutama? Mis ta ei paku
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et tema mõtleb, et sa praegult ikka kirjutad siia ennem oli siin lihtsalt tekst Tallinn oli.
Õpetaja: Tema ikka mõtleb, et. Kuule, sa kirjutad siin midagi? Noh, teksti. Lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Mm. Kui ma tahangi, et mul on siin Kirjas location. See peab olema minu õigus.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan, et mul on siin igal pool lihtsalt location. See on minu õigus, ma võin seda teha. Aga kui ma tahan viidata et ma kirjutan mingit muutujat, siis ma vaatan jälle, kus ma asun. Kas ma olen Tag I sees?
Õpetaja: Kas ma olen atribuudi sees? Näiteks, ma ei tea, mingi näiteks. See on atribuut Näed,
Õpetaja: siia saad kirjutada atribuutide sisse, Saad kohe viidata objekte,
Õpetaja: Oota, Ei saa. Kool on hea. Veel nii.
Õpetaja: Mina olen tagide. Vahel Siis tagide vahel mistahes teksti kirjutada. Aga mina tahan, öelda et näiteks Siia otsa tuleb nüüd mingisugune muutuja, siis See on see tööriist poele Anda märku, et nüüd tuleb muutuja.
Õpetaja: Noh, siin, kui hakkad kirjutama, l juba tuleb. Siin on ka viga vaata, mis saab kohe tekkida. Jälle paned Locations?
Õpetaja: Noh, mis siit välja tuleb?
Õpetaja: Siin ongi kogu su massiiv, onju? Ja siis tuleb mingi massiiv, et siin on igal pool väiksed väiksed ohud, onju? Mina tahan siit valida. Ainsuses Location.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ikka ei Ole õige, sest nüüd on üks Location objekt sikupilli prisma. Tallinn Transaction types ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ja,
Õpetaja: noh, nüüd tuleb see a ja Tallinn, onju? No nüüd ongi. Saame aru, et tegelikult mul mingit muud teksti ei ole vaja. Aga kui ma tahan, ma saan
Õpetaja: I love optima, Isegi võibolla vahepeal, jah.
Õpetaja: Noh, tuli. Tallinn. Tallinn Tartu.
Õpetaja: Võime korra proovida. Võtan Tartu.
Õpetaja: Ta on Tallinn, et ta on pärnu.
Õpetaja: Ta on kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: Tundub, et see töötab. Noh, ega siin midagi muud ei ole. Kui nüüd on vaja, siis mis asi see on? Lihtsalt On vaja teada, et mis asi on see Niiöelda see on asukohanimi. Noh, paneme jälle topelt Loogilised sulud. Location. Tab punkt.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis Ma valin siia Location Name i Love optimising. Vahepeal ka jälle. Et tuleb paika,
Õpetaja: On juba Tallinn sikupilli Prisma tundi. Selver ja prisma tundub, et töötab
Õpetaja: nüüd Hetkel on kõigil siin sularaha sisse sularaha väljamaksed. Noh, miks? Sellepärast, et hetkel on nii sisse kirjutatud?
Õpetaja: Aa, okei, mis ee, toimub Nüüd,
Õpetaja: Mis siin siis tegema peab. Nüüd
Õpetaja: Transaction Type on vaja.
Õpetaja: Okei, nõus olen. Ma olen täielikult nõus. Tegelikult mina olen.
Õpetaja: Tegelikult on veel vaja transaction Type name. I on lausa Vaja on ju?
Õpetaja: No Loomulikult, kustutame ära need. Me ju ei tea ju, mitu siit neid tuleb, onju? Me Ei saa öelda, et kolm tuleb. Me ei saa öelda, neli tuleb. Me ei saa öelda, et kaks tuleb. Me tegelt ei saa isegi kindlad olla, et seal ühtegi on.
Õpetaja: See asi vist peab kuidagi teistmoodi tulema. Dünaamiliselt on nii.
Õpetaja: Kuidas Kuidas saab tulla? Seda Dünaamiliselt
Õpetaja: su tööriist ei ole kuidagi vahepeal muutunud. Nagu
Õpetaja: No ütles, kõva häälega. Mis sa ütlesid, Before? On vaja jälle, et meil on vaja seda elementi teha teatud
Õpetaja: arvutsükleid. Vi for.
Õpetaja: No ma nüüd küsin uuesti. Mis See, mall on, mis meil aitab Nagu alguse kätte Küsimärk.
Õpetaja: Siin, küsimärk, Noh, ei ole raske meelde jätta. Tegelikult paremale poole peab tulema mingi kollektsioon.
Õpetaja: No mis on see kollektsioon, mida me soovime kasutada, kui me vaatame oma sõnumit,
Õpetaja: mis on Locations?
Õpetaja: Aga Locations on ju.
Õpetaja: Locationsis on niuksed, objektid. Ja
Õpetaja: no mis ma siia kirjutan? Üheks
Õpetaja: no transaction types ei saa kirjutada. Sellepärast ei paku.
Õpetaja: Aga Ei saagi pakkuda ju.
Õpetaja: Kus on siis nagu peaks olema Locations.
Õpetaja: Ahah, vot see on juba parem sellepärast kas vastab tõele. Vaata, et selles Location I sees on. Just proovisime. Äkki selleks võtmeks
Õpetaja: seda. Kuvame linna. Kuvame? Ütleme. Location Punkt location Id location Punkt Cityname. Kasutasime. Nüüd vist oleks vaja öelda veel, et kollektsioon on meil location punkt.
Õpetaja: Ahhaa.
Õpetaja: Ütleme Location ainsuses. Punkt.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, mida?
Õpetaja: Vaata, kui Siin näitab nende puhul ära. Et paremal pool näitab. String String number järsku Transaction Typesel ei näita tüüpi. Miks?
Õpetaja: Sest et ta on ta on massiiv.
Õpetaja: Palun väga.
Õpetaja: Siit saab ta nüüd ju kätte. Konkreetse asukoha. Transaction Type Id. Ühe objekti Transaction Type Id.
Õpetaja: Nüüd mis meil, on siia vaja. Nüüd on jälle. Vaadake, mis läheb selle muutuja nimeks.
Õpetaja: See on väga lihtne, mis läheb selle muutuja nimeks?
Õpetaja: Jaa, võimsuses. Vaata seda Pikalt ei ole mõtet panna mingile Location transaction type. Lihtsalt tõks tõks vasakule, kui on niukene inglise keelne sõna millega nii saab teha,
Õpetaja: kas See võiks olla meie üksik objekt. Kui Transaction Types on tegelikult see info, millega me siin tsükeldame.
Õpetaja: Kui neil on types, siis selle muuta, nimi on
Õpetaja: Transaction Type. Nüüd meil on jälle. Mis asi, mis? Mis asi see on? Süntaksi mõttes, mis asi see on?
Õpetaja: See on sildikene Siin taga toimetavad objektid Programmilised. Nüüd me saame viidata nendele nendele. Mis see, miks on punane joon all?
Õpetaja: Ghee on puudu.
Õpetaja: No lähme siis Siia paneme uue atribuudi. Seekord oled targemad ja ei kirjuta kiivaid kirjutame kõigepealt.
Õpetaja: Kool ongi, onju? Niikuinii tuleb see kuskilt muutujast. No me just Kui me tekstina kirjutame väärtuse sisse, siis seal mingit erinevust pole. Mis on nüüd meie mängumaa,
Õpetaja: millega me saame Nüüd, mis me saame kirjutada siia.
Õpetaja: Okei, noh, sealt juba Artur juba tuleb. Enamvähem
Õpetaja: meie mängumaa on hetkel endiselt sama, Mõtle, mis on meie mängumaa. Meil on ligipääs alati Databloki asjadele. Recardness.
Õpetaja: Ee Hetke seisuga on meie mängumaa location objekt on ju Locations Objekt oli niikuinii juba seal. Data blokis.
Õpetaja: Meil on Olemas Ka Transaction Type.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis on transaction? Type I sees. Noh, vaatame mis siin. Transaction Type I Sees. On niuksed objektid.
Õpetaja: Üks transaction type. On selline objekt, kas on nii?
Õpetaja: No on, no mis mõtted siis? Ee, on?
Õpetaja: Palun, mis ma kirjutan siia
Õpetaja: ja täpselt.
Õpetaja: Ütle kõva häälega, raisk.
Õpetaja: Ja
Õpetaja: nüüd see ei ole number Vaata selle keeks. Aga me ju teame, et need väärtused on igal juhul erinevad selles tsüklis siin Ei ole nagu,
Õpetaja: et kui üks muutub, siis ju kõik muutub kohe jälle. Vaata, teab, et ta peab uuesti joonistama,
Õpetaja: et siin Id D Ei ole, aga seda ei ole ka vaja.
Õpetaja: Nüüd meil on siin kõigil. Nüüd. Kahjuks on lõpptulemus. On veel hetkel veel nagu ainsana. Mis on vale, et on nagu sularaha sisse. Sularaha, sisse sularaha sisse. Ilmselt saab sularaha seal kohas sisse panna, onju? Aga
Õpetaja: see on see, lihtsalt et on siin see string Tekst on ju?
Õpetaja: Seda Me ei taha, et on sisse kirjutatud. Ta oli meil mall alguses. Mis ma siia Kirjutan
Õpetaja: topelt. Loogilised sulud, Mis ma nüüd kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Need samad, mis tüübid ei ole? Tüübid, sildid.
Õpetaja: No keegi juba ütles vähemalt sealt tagantpoolt Margarita Ütles kõva häälega
Õpetaja: ja ei ole. Ei ole transaction. Kui ma hakkan kirjutama Transaction Type name, siis ma ei näe seda. Miks sellepärast, et Te peate saama aru.
Õpetaja: Vaatame jälle korra andmeid.
Õpetaja: Transaction Type name on selle transaction Type objekti Sees. Sa ei saa kohe kirjutada.
Õpetaja: Sa pead viitama. Kõigepealt sellele.
Õpetaja: Üks üks objekt korraga, on onju? Sa viitad kõigepealt Ei, üks objekt. Transaction Type punkt. Transaction Type
Õpetaja: ehk siis see, mille jaoks me selle võtme üldse tegime Mitte selle Ghee pärast. Ju
Õpetaja: tahaks. Nagu seda infot kätte saada.
Õpetaja: Siis siis
Õpetaja: ütleme Transaction Type. Jällegi, vaata, Kui panete S I, siis siis ta viitab millegile muule. No seda ei saaks. Seal saab enda niikuinii vaimsuses panete punkti, pakub Transaction Type Name,
Õpetaja: kuna panime üle nüüd selle joone.
Õpetaja: Ee, I love optimising. Ma ei tea, kas te tõstate alla või ei tõsta, Tõesti ei saa. Olla.
Õpetaja: Ma panen I love optimising. Ma ei tea, mis ma kogu aeg siniseks teen. I Love Optimizing töötab niisama ka.
Õpetaja: Ta läks liiga palju paremale. Näed nüüd, see tiiv algab siit. Võibolla see ei mahuks siia kuidagi ära. Või juba läheb üle
Õpetaja: Umbes nii ta olekski, see on Okei, meil on üks tiv.
Õpetaja: Mida me. See on kogu tiiv. Me teeme seda tsükliliselt. Tagide vahel on see
Õpetaja: topelt. Loogiliselt ei sugugi ta öeldud, et anna mulle sisu
Õpetaja: ja jaanes.
Õpetaja: Noh, tegelikult see kõik on väga loogiline.
Õpetaja: Niipea kui sa hakkad mõtlema Aa sildikestele ja nendele objektidesse Objektide objektidele seal taga.
Õpetaja: Ja saame aru, et me peame suhtlema nende objektidega läbi sildikeste, sest nii see käibki muud moodi ei ole Võimalik, lihtsalt. Meil on samamoodi. Avas on objekt orienteeritud programmeerimine. Meil on objektid. Nad elavad kuskil mälus. Neil on mingid referentsid.
Õpetaja: Mingisugused mäluviited, Asjad Kus nad elavad On ju? Aga kuidas me siis programmis saame niiöelda? Kirjutame koodi. See on keel. Programmeerimiskeeld. Me räägime programmiga. Palun võta see Objekt.
Õpetaja: Käid tsükliliselt läbi ja tee Html elemente sellise struktuuriga. Table diagram. Pane sinna. Selle objekti Seest.
Õpetaja: Väärtus siin. Teine. Vaata või see proov Vaatab, mis iganes. Pane sinna. Allocation name.
Õpetaja: No ja siis sa suhtled temaga edasi. Aga tead, siin objekti sees on veel niuke väline. Kui
Õpetaja: Ma nüüd sooviksin seda kasutada. Ma sooviksin, et sa nüüd teed jälle ühe tsükli ja teeksid nüüd siin elemente mulle nii palju, kui on siin nagu neid objekte.
Õpetaja: Nii igal tsüklil Ole tähelepanelik. Vaata seda. Kui need kunagi muutuvad, siis Ilmselt pead koodi uuesti jooksma. See On see Key ja pane sinna sisse sinna iga Tv sisse. Üks tekst. Võta see palun sealt. Transaction Type I küljest on Niukene väline kui Transaction Type name.
Õpetaja: Me räägime silt. Silt, silt, Väli Väli Väli objekt on seal taustal
Õpetaja: nii ainult mis me peame teadma. Me peame õppima ära Nagu need asjad. Aa süntaksi asjad veits nagu ära. Idee juba on nagu selge. Me me räägime programmiga. Ma räägin jaamascriptiga.
Õpetaja: Ma räägin selle raamistikuga juttu kogu aeg.
Õpetaja: Terve see terve See kool on üks, Ruth,
Õpetaja: et nagu palun joonista mulle. Ee, alustame seda juttu, et tee mul Üks Niukene leht. Vaata, kohe. Alguses on seal päises on Niukene tekst, pangaautomaadid. Ma ütlen talle, mida ma tahan näha.
Õpetaja: Mina Ütlen päeva lõpus, et kõik taustal on jälle ka ju nullid ja ühed. Ja mida iganes tegelikult,
Õpetaja: et selles mõttes, et ega protsessor ei ole seal, mingi Aa, nüüd on see H. H. Üks pangaautomaadid vaja nagu. Teha. Vaata, tema niimoodi. Ei, Mõtle, Vaata, on ju
Õpetaja: Protsessor töötab Ee, null ja Üks Ja üks ja null on ju. Nemad ütleb niimoodi, et lõpuks see taandub kõik selleks. Aga ongi see, et nagu kuidas me saame suhelda selle protsessoriga. Praegu on siin mitu kihti all pool, mis ise teevad selle nullid ja ühed meile ära, seal kus vaja, vaata, aga Praegu Meie suhtluskeem on selline.
Õpetaja: Me saame selle programmiga suhelda. Niimoodi
Õpetaja: seame sõnu õiges järjekorras ritta. Me kasutame õigeid sümboleid. Me hoiame kinni reeglitest Mis selle niiöelda standardiga on välja mõeldud selle keele standardiga.
Õpetaja: Jälgime neid reegleid, Kasutame neid võtteid. Noh, ongi kokku lepitud võte. Kui Sa kirjutad Atribuudi V Four Voe teab, mida taustal lõpuks peab tegema.
Õpetaja: See lõpptulemus ei ole ju päris selline. See ei ole ju brauseris. See ei Ole selline kood.
Õpetaja: Before ist ei ole seal haisugi.
Õpetaja: Selles mõttes,
Õpetaja: et ostal on ikka jaovascript, mis ta teeb ära ja Voe istub siin peal. Vaata, et me ei peaks seda Jaovascripti Päris Nagu vanilla. Niiöelda native kirjutama.
Õpetaja: See on suhtlemine.
Õpetaja: Meil on siin objektid, andmed ja meil on sildid, mis on seotud nende andmetega.
Õpetaja: Davai Ee, mulle, Tundub et see siin läbi vist ei ole.
Õpetaja: Terrorist sai täna nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Ei, Kus
Õpetaja: ahah. Sul on õigus, et. Vaata, Ee, true or false. Vaata, on ju. Ee. Kui mina panen ee niukse koha, mille kohta me Saame Vastuse siis Locations andmed uuendatakse. Pane see sealt respons data sinna sisse ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Kui me saame Errori, siis mis iganes meil Oli ennem
Õpetaja: Tartu Erroris. Me kuidagi ei reseti. Seda või ei pane nagu neid nulli. Saate mõttes aru, on nii?
Õpetaja: No aga siis seda peakski tegema.
Õpetaja: Ee lähme vaatame. Kus on siis see osa?
Õpetaja: See olukord siin. Me ei pea üldse muretsema. See leht on igavesti Tsau,
Õpetaja: aga Nüüd me saame aru, et ainult selles error message I näitamisel jääb vana kama. Jääb ette, kui on kõik linnad ja pärnu, meil tuleb teade. Aga see annab justkui, nagu, et, noh, pärnus on kolm. Kohta Tallinn Tartus viljandis. Põhimõtteliselt siin on minilinnad, on pärnus.
Õpetaja: Samad asjad mis Tallinnas. Tallinna peegeldus. Suvepealinn Ongi ju.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ei tea, mida see Tartu seal teeb. Vaata,
Õpetaja: täna tahab ka kuidagi olla mingi, Mis see, Mis pealinn? Tartu on? Suve. Su pärn on suvepealinn. Start on,
Õpetaja: ah? Lgbt vä. Okei, kui sa nii ütled Tartusse, enam ei Julge minna
Õpetaja: pannakse kohe tempel peale, et sa oled ka see vend. Vaata, kui nii, siis on, Okei,
Õpetaja: its. Okay, to be gay.
Õpetaja: Nii, lähme edasi. Ee, et me saame aru, et mingi jama on Nüüd mina küsin. Ee. Esiteks kui kogu selle renderdamine
Õpetaja: käib niiöelda massiivi pealt Locations, et The Four tsükliga võtab täpselt nii. Mitu elementi on?
Õpetaja: Nii Mitu rida tuleb?
Õpetaja: Siis? Kuidas on Niuke? Väga nüüd seda olukorda lahendada, et siin On nagu kolm rida. Nagu eelmisest päringust alles. Kuidas Kuidas me nad ära kaotame?
Õpetaja: Mida me peame. Manipul, Mis mis joonistab selle? Vaata, on Locations. Selles oleme veendunud, onju? Okei, sest me teame, et midagi selle peab tegema.
Õpetaja: No siis ma kirjutan This Locations.
Õpetaja: Ta peab uue sisu saama. Selles oleme ka veendunud. Ja vaata sisu pealt ju näidatakse meile, et võrdusmärk tuleb igal juhul.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on, küsimus, et mida kuradit siia paremale poole kirjutada,
Õpetaja: tühjus.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ma päris tühjuse jätan, siis on süntaks katki. Peale võrdsusmärki midagi peab tulema see on string.
Õpetaja: See, mis Võib isegi töötada. Võibolla ma ei tea, ei oleks väga ilus, aga töötab justkui.
Õpetaja: Ilusam Oleks natukene. Seda, et tegemist on siis tühja massiiviga, Mäletate, kuidas objekti on? Võimalik luua? Palun väga objekt.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, mis me siin objekti asemele tahame teha tühi. See oli tühi Objekt oli. Polnud mitte midagi sees. Ühtegi välja.
Õpetaja: Tühjad kandilised. Sul oled nüüd. See on korrektne. Proovime, ma Ütlen. Pärnu pole midagi.
Õpetaja: No võibolla nüüd Mingi üks asi võibolla veel häiriks, kui vaataks seda taaski ennast, onju? Kurat, ma panin kinni ja ei pannud,
Õpetaja: Noh, siin on natuke teistsugune Disain, et mis? Mis? Endiselt nagu ei ole nagu perfi.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ee. No laius on veel eraldi teema.
Õpetaja: No Errori asukoht on ka, kus Ta on, nagu et. Kas me paneme ta siia alla või mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Mina pakuks, et tegelikult äkki teeme ikkagi niimoodi et paneme selle sinna samma veergu. Kus on see tabel? Ise tuleks siia,
Õpetaja: et lähme otsime selle ülesse. Selle mis on real viis
Õpetaja: by the way kui, Te tahate kuskile reale minna? Näiteks, et, ee, te saate. Te töötate töö Environment is. Ja seal on niimoodi, et kui tuleb mingid vead Ja asjad siis on niuksed, Logifailid,
Õpetaja: tekstifailid, mis vahel natukene ütlevad. Ja see tekstifailis võib näiteks öelda, et ee, klassis nimega Atms View Aa, Real Seitsekümmend seitse. Midagi on kaka.
Õpetaja: Siis kuidas seda teha on see, et te teete selle lahti ja vajutate Control G, ma ei oska ühtegi mõtet mõelda, mida see G võiks representida.
Õpetaja: Go, siis te panete kodu. Noh, seitsekümmend seitse variantrit.
Õpetaja: Oled selle real, võetakse panna. Kontrol G Ja öelda, kont reale viis.
Õpetaja: Põmm.
Õpetaja: Teinekord, kui te näete minu ekraanil midagi ja failid on juba pikad, lohisevad Control G Go File,
Õpetaja: mis me tahame teha, on see, et tõstame siit selle Control Xiga ära
Õpetaja: ja paneme ta siia. Samma Veergu teibli ülesse.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis võibolla tuleb Natukene parem,
Õpetaja: Kui sa seda soovid, siis kohverit. Aga järgmise kommitiga sa tuled mulle järgi ja.
Õpetaja: Okei, aga las ta jääb korra siia, siis Ta on nagu peaaegu selline nagu meil. Noh, see on hästi. Natuke nihkes, see pilt või mis iganes, onju, Aga mõte on sama, mis ikka häirib veel.
Õpetaja: Aga need Heederid on ju veits. Oleks nagu.
Õpetaja: No aga mida me saaksime sellega teha? Selle headeriga
Õpetaja: Raud ei tule niikuinii. Sellepärast Locations is pole midagi, Ta on ju No ei ole, midagi.
Õpetaja: Aga Mis mõtted on sellega? Mis mõtted on? Konkreetselt selle asjaga siin?
Õpetaja: Kuidas Kümme
Õpetaja: no? Aga, Kui ta pärnu näitaks siis, mis read siia tulevad mis? Teenused Asukohad noh? See, on juba ära märgitud
Õpetaja: ei, Ja,
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen, mina nagu peidaks selle ära. Vaata, et. Et ta minule nagu selline asi, nagu ei meeldiks, nagu kui juba nihukene suund on valitud.
Õpetaja: Noh, aga siis ongi küsimus, et
Õpetaja: kus ma seda ära nagu saaks peita. Vaata, onju? Mis teie mõtted on?
Õpetaja: Okei, nüüd on vaja Lihtsalt ainult leida õige element ülesse. Tema esimene tag, mis reaalselt võiks juttu olla
Õpetaja: Kakskümmend
Õpetaja: võimalik. See on okei, ja see töötaks, aga mina Juba mõtleks siis, et äkki siis mõtleks natukene suurema suurema pildiga.
Õpetaja: Võibolla läheks natukene väljapoole, veel.
Õpetaja: Et kogu seda tabelit ju siis ei ole mõtet näidata, on ju?
Õpetaja: Siis saaks ju teha siia Wave
Õpetaja: Ja jällegi Ee saaks vaadata. Päriselt saaks vaadata. Näiteks, et Locations
Õpetaja: Ma. Ma näitan, Kuidas pikalt saab? Siis Vaatame, kas saab kuidagi lühemalt Mina ei Mäleta, Kas Location Il on Size või Lengt Lengton? Pigem
Õpetaja: saaks öelda, et Näita seda.
Õpetaja: See peab rehkenduma, on nii? Kui me mängiksime praegu Aa. Lenktiga, mis Lihtsalt ütleb, et mitu elementi on siin sees
Õpetaja: siis, kuidas Ee, saab. Millal on mõtet näidata seda tabelit?
Õpetaja: Kui lenks on?
Õpetaja: Kuulge, suurem kui
Õpetaja: aga null elementiga, siis on mõtet näidata,
Õpetaja: aga kui on Üks element siis juba vist võiks näidata,
Õpetaja: et kui linked on suurem kui null,
Õpetaja: ehk siis on positiivne. Me ei taha ehitust panna, kui vähegi võimalik,
Õpetaja: siis see peaks olema niimoodi. Et kui on Tartu.
Õpetaja: Kui on pärnu, kui on Tallinn, et kui on midagi näidata, siis näitan,
Õpetaja: Kui Ei ole midagi näidata, siis vist ei näita, on ju?
Õpetaja: Tead, seda Tabelit ei ole mõtet näidata,
Õpetaja: kui see on nagu meie huvisoov.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ütlen ka see on puhtalt tegelikult siin suuresti pandud. Lihtsalt õppimise eesmärgil. See oleks ka väga okei, kui siin lihtsalt ei tule. Ühtegi teadet ja
Õpetaja: ei ole ühtegi tulemust. Eriti kui sul on filtreid rohkem kui üks.
Õpetaja: Aa saab ikka aga mina arvan et, ee, mäletate, Kuidas ee. Stringiga Wf töötas
Õpetaja: Automaatselt, nagu me. Tegelt me. Me ei vaadanud Vf iga vaid isegi kuskilt mujalt. Tegelt oli W If iga Alerti, vaata palun väga,
Õpetaja: kuidas siin on, et kui on Stringil sisu, siis näitab. Ei ole. Vaadake, Kui lühike süntaks on, ma pakun,
Õpetaja: ma Ei ole kindel, et äkki saab massiiviga teha täpselt sama triki, et ei pea lenfti vaatama, vaid ütles, et ta lihtsalt saab aru, et Tegemist on massiiviga ja tema jaoks truu. On Ta siis, kui seal on mingeid elemente. Vaatan kõigepealt
Õpetaja: on või Ei, ole,
Õpetaja: ei ole, see ei tööta nii. Miks? Sest et ma ju näen seda tabelit. Seal ei ole küll ühtegi rida. Kahjuks ee, massiiviga ei tööta.
Õpetaja: Ma ei tea, kas tal on veel mingisuguseid meetodeid mingi või midagi. Ee,
Õpetaja: see võib ka olla Chat i chat I, küsimus, et kas seda on kuidagi lihtsamalt teha. Aga see on ka väga fine. Näita tabelit, kui lent on rohkem kui null,
Õpetaja: Noh, siin, ongi see vaata, et ee, Noh, seda võib küsida. Mina ei viitsi Kuulutada oma token Eid. Keegi tahab küsida, kui tahab, et et kas seda sellist nagu Massiivi võrdlust saab ka kuidagi muud moodi panna. Aga teeme seda vahetunni ajal. Ärme seda tee. Liigume edasi.
Õpetaja: Nii, Kas nüüd on ära tehtud?
Õpetaja: Taas?
Õpetaja: No Ma pakun, et on.
Õpetaja: Ee, meile tulevad linnad vastavad. City Id le.
Õpetaja: Meil tuleb ei leitud ühtegi pangaautomaati. Kõikidel teiste errorite puhul suunatakse kasutada Error Viole Fine.
Õpetaja: Ahah. Üks väikene trikk
Õpetaja: oma lõppproduktis. Aa, selline asi. Vaata, Navigate. Päriselt ka juhtuma, onju? Kui midagi läheb valesti, siis
Õpetaja: midagi. Oleks valesti arenduse ajaks, teeks mina niimoodi, et Ma kommenteeriks selle päris push Imise välja. Miks
Õpetaja: sa täidad mingisugust vormi, Sa Noh, Proged alles Sa täidad mingisugust vormi. Aa, sa mingid asjad on valed Sa vajutad mingit nuppu. Mingi sõnum läheb teele ja ta lükkab kohe Ups, Midagi läheks valesti. Ja need, ee, tähteandmed, mis sul olid seal ees, on igaveseks kadunud, et, noh, Packiga tulles
Õpetaja: vorm laetakse, uuesti, Ma kommenteeriks selle Ajutiselt praegu välja. Aga igal pool programmeerimise mõttes. Ee, niiöelda juba teeks seda siia Võin panna mingi duduu ka peale, et
Õpetaja: ee, peale arendust Lülita sisse.
Õpetaja: Saate aru, et sa lihtsalt. Kui päriselt hakkab see juhtuma neile nagu arenduse käigus. See on tüütu, et sa sa ei näe nagu, vaata, et. Noh, kui ma vajutasin mingit nuppu, on ju et mul olid seal mingisugune sisu seal veebilehel, et ma sain vea, et Sa ei saa kuidagi seda tee pugida nii mõnusalt. Kuidas,
Õpetaja: mille teeb komponenti?
Õpetaja: Aa, sa Novaga on sul on õigus, Muidugi ei ole.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma nüüd räägin. Vaata, ma räägin siis. Aa, me teeme selle igal juhul nagu on ju.
Õpetaja: Kui me me lõppkokkuvõttes kunagi tulevad klikid siia, peale. Näed selle asukoha infot koos pildiga ja editi asjad tulevad juurde, onju?
Õpetaja: Niipea, kui hakkavad tekkima mingisugused nupu vajutused ja meetodid ja käivitamised, Siis on juba viimane aeg teha sellest komponenti.
Õpetaja: Sest et niipea, kui sa kutsud välja meetodeid, mis asuvad selles Atm klassis, Vaata, siis, ee, See need asjad lähevad lihtsalt keeruliseks. Ta ei oska enam seda ekstraktide komponendiks. Normaalselt või niimoodi, et oskaks aru saada
Õpetaja: praegult mingit klõbistamist. Siin ei ole.
Õpetaja: Kõik Kuvab, et see on täielikult perfekt hetk teha sellest nüüd lõpuks komponent.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, asi, mida te peate arvestama, on see, et, Ee, kui te võtaksite mingid muud asjad ka kaasa,
Õpetaja: siis kui praegult. Ma korra tõmban selle teibli kokku, Kui ma võtaks ja ütleks et Tee sellest üks uus komponent.
Õpetaja: Nüüd selles uues komponendist. See osa, mis me selekteerime, satubki samamoodi templeid vahele.
Õpetaja: Mis asi siin ei ole nagu reeglitega kooskõlas. Kui see satuks template vahele,
Õpetaja: ma. Pole seda veel. Väga rõhutanud.
Õpetaja: Template Il peaks alati olema ainult üks,
Õpetaja: Aga kui me praegu Võtame I siis mitu elementi on?
Õpetaja: Ongi ainult
Õpetaja: üks element, et lihtsalt ekstraktimisel. Alati seda Arvestage, et siin. On väga okei võtta Võtad siin mingeid asju. Aga te peate ka natukene mõtlema. Juba Etteruttavalt, et. Oot, oot, aga uues kohas. Ta satub samamoodi templeid vahele ja seal peaks olema. Üks Child
Õpetaja: On see arusaadav, Aga võtamegi siis selle Mis selle nimi pidi üldse. Olema?
Õpetaja: Location Stable. Ee, võtame selle osa siit parem Klõps Refactor Extract View Component.
Õpetaja: Ee, teie võite seda juba teha ja panna selle nime ära ka. Location Stable. Aa, mina lihtsalt pulli pärast Vaatan kas. Ee. Mis asi selle asja nimi oli? Vaata, kuidas ta kutsus seda. Asja.
Õpetaja: Abstract View komponent.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma korra vaatan. Lihtsalt huvipärast Ee, Settings Keep.
Õpetaja: Otsin seda saab kahtepidi otsida. Saad otsida Shortcut? Ide järgi? Kui ma ütlen siin Control alt, m näiteks mida see teeb
Õpetaja: Sõltuvalt kontekstis. Kus sa midagi oled? Näete ekstrakt. Meetod on siin. Näiteks onju.
Õpetaja: Saad otsida ka siis nende nimetuste järgi, kui mina panen ekstrakt Vae komponent.
Õpetaja: Ma saaksin siia panna ka oma keyboard shortcut,
Õpetaja: Aga ma ei oskaks mitte midagi välja mõelda praegu, et, Ee, aga saate mõttest aru, kui te hakkate tegema mingisuguseid. Samasuguseid tegevusi. Te võite ka mõelda seda? Vaata, et Out of the Box ei ole nagu mingi shortcut, Aga Äkki on nagu mõistlik endal teha
Õpetaja: praegu. Seda ei tee
Õpetaja: ee. See, on nii harvad korrad kuidas. Ekstraktid et, ma korra hiilt katsuda Nagu Ei, tapa mind ära.
Õpetaja: Aga tead, kui ma igapäevaselt seda teeksin, siis mul oleks shortcut. Ma ei viitsiks ka niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma ikkagi tahaks toimetada. Ma tahaks jätta endale võimaluse. Ee, kus sa oled nüüd? Refaktor?
Õpetaja: Jah, ja Locations.
Õpetaja: Okei, palun.
Õpetaja: Terve seda reaal kaheksateist, onju?
Õpetaja: Ma Vist võtsin tag I tag I või selle ühe tag I nagu niimoodi ma võtsin. Niimoodi Noh, see oli mul kokku surutud, on ju, Muidu, vaata, niimoodi võib tulla. Vigu
Õpetaja: on ju, et kui sa põhimõtteliselt see osa koodist, mis me on selline,
Õpetaja: aga mulle meeldib loomulikult, eks Track Ida niimoodi, et ma tõmban asjad kokku. Ma tegin konkreetselt praegult niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Siin võib olla vist see värk. Vaata, et ta niimoodi ei taha lubada. On ju, et see tab on ka siin sees. Ma vaatan, kas lubab või mitte.
Õpetaja: Lubas, Ee, vanasti ta minu meelest veidi Vaata,
Õpetaja: ee, ta on paremaks läinud. A, et praegu ma tegin nii, kui ma tegin niimoodi,
Õpetaja: vahet pole kuidas Ta ütleb, et see saab Tehtud track you componed.
Õpetaja: Nii we are not done. Nagu selles mõttes ta tegi selle ära. Ee, hetkel ta teeb Templeid ja script I Tagurpidi on ju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Tõmban need mõlemad kokku.
Õpetaja: Võtan selle Control Iks, Teen paar entrit ja paned hoopis siia ülesse.
Õpetaja: Aa, ma tegelikult hästi Natukene juba. Aa, olen hakanud mõtlema. Vaata, et ma isegi näen seda loogikat, Tõesti, et miks see võiks eespool olla
Õpetaja: ma vaikselt tegelikult, ee, juba flirin selle mõttega, et kui ma oma klassirahad projekti olen läbi teinud, siis ma ütlen, ee. Ütlen lihtsalt Cloudile, et ole hea vaheta Igal pool need kaks omavahel ära, et Script on üleval etember ite all
Õpetaja: puhtalt. Sellepärast, et kui tõesti see on standard,
Õpetaja: siis ma ei viitsiks kunagi, et kui ma hakkan kuskil töötama, et seal vaatab vastu nagu harjumatu asi. Eriti see ga ma nagu näen, kui pingsalt sa Tegelikult pead niikuinii kogu aeg vaatama, mis sul seal Scriptis on ja mõtlema hoopis sellele, enne, kui sa üldse selle visuaalile lähete,
Õpetaja: kuigi, noh, Hästi, mõnus on maanduda lehele ja näha mingisugust skripti asemel on näha mingeid tuttavaid asju.
Õpetaja: No vaata, Point, ongi see, vaata et et kogu et sa pead nägema. Vaata, et mis andmed siia sisse tulevad, enne kui on Point I. Seda vaadata, On ju, et ta on val, Ta on nagu teistpidi veel. Ei ole ka meile hilja ümber harjuda.
Õpetaja: Veel Ei, ole hilja. Nagu. Noh, praegu pole veel nii palju faile, Vaata, on ju võibolla selle projektiga. Las ta olla, Vaata, et. Noh, mulle meeldib keskenduda sellele visuaalsele poolele enamuse ajast,
Õpetaja: sest et kui ma Tulen kuskilt lehelt ja tulen Vaatan siis ma ka enne tahan nagu näha neid asju.
Õpetaja: Ee, ja ma ütlen ka, et ega päeva lõpuks Vaata, ee, vaata, siin on mõned reeglid, mis ei ole nagu kokkuleppelised nagu väga Okei java meetod algab väikse tähega jaava muutuja algab väikse tähega.
Õpetaja: Seal tekib igasugused probleemid.
Õpetaja: Niipea, kui te tahate panna muutujat suure tähega. Kui haavasse jõuan, siis näitan, et on mingid reeglid, mida sa ei saa painutada
Õpetaja: päris nagu taval. Aga teised on nagu niuksed. Üldised tavad. Kuidas nagu inimestele meeldib asju teha, et on nagu tehnoloogia pealt Justkui pandud. Nagu, et tava jaavas näeb ette, nii et dokumentatsioonis kirjutab Ka see on ära dokumenteeritud. Minge palun võtke jaava dokumentatsioon lahti. Ülikuiv lugemine. Mina ei tea, kes kunagi üldse nagu dokumentatsiooni jaavas on lugenud.
Õpetaja: Ma olen ja küsinud midagi. Kui ma hakkan sealt vaatama, tegelikult inimesed teevad seda. Nad lähevad, loevad. Aga see on hästi kuivad. Tehniline jutt. Nagu mingi ülirõve.
Õpetaja: Ee, midagi head seal ei ole.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis seal On ka ära öeldud, et muutuja nimi algab. Kuidas
Õpetaja: tegelikult see on Nagu paigas, Aga see asi, et templeid üleval ee script all või Vastupidi, jah. See võib olla välja kujunenud tavaliselt, sest et alguses ta oli tegelikult ikkagi niimoodi. Ma ei tea, kuidas aja jooksul,
Õpetaja: kui kui Sa teed uue Selle Vaata siis. Alguses ei olnud niimoodi, et ta topib seda templetit allapoole. Vanasti oli, et oli üleval ja ainuke asi, Mis sa kohe ära kustutada Tahaks toppida mingit kogu aeg, mida ei kasutanud.
Õpetaja: Olge kõik, aga nüüd enam ei ole nii, Okei, see selleks Just
Õpetaja: või näiteks üks uus linn ja mingi
Õpetaja: kohe kohal juurde, Siis automaatselt tuleks meie saia tulla,
Õpetaja: sest kõik need andmed tulevad kuradi internetist Ja ja lihtsalt tuled Stoplight I näidiste järgi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ainuke asi, mis on veel viimane asi, on teha see, et iga kord, kui sa ekstraktid Mingisugust koodi. Ta topib selle sinna samasse kausta. Kus sa selle ekstrakti? Seda, et. Vabandust, see Location Stable, kus ta nüüd on? Ma Ei näe ju.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei, mina teen korda. Ee, tahtsin panna oli onju?
Õpetaja: Ee, Ja vaadake, ta ei ole nagu ideaalne. Ta ütleb, et Vaatame, kas ta saab hakkama. Ma ütlen, et see on Locations.
Õpetaja: Ee, table. Kas te panite ka samamoodi? Nüüd keegi järgi või te olete nii tublid
Õpetaja: ja. Aga ma panen selle location järgi tulla. Ka see taask on põhimõtteliselt läbi Ee Location refaktor,
Õpetaja: aga vaadake, kui ma tulen Nüüd name Section Isse, mis ta on Endiselt
Õpetaja: Ta ei oska seda stringi ära muuta. Et ta ei ole tegelikult ee, voetöriist või default, Ütleme nii,
Õpetaja: et, ee. See on see, nagu mis ma nüüd teeksin, on see, et ma panen Control Shift Control F on. Otsi siit Failist. Control Shift F on. Otsi üle projekti.
Õpetaja: Ee, kui ma midagi nihukest muutisin, siis ma otsiks niimoodi. Locations View, See, millest, mis ta ära muutsin.
Õpetaja: Näete kuskil on ikka veel Atm Views? On see klotsi mul nüüd kogemata valesti, on ju?
Õpetaja: On põrguline.
Õpetaja: Noh, Refaktor.
Õpetaja: Refaktor. Siit Alt Kinnitan, Ma vaatan, kas siin muutus ka.
Õpetaja: Location Stable Location Korras, ma jälle otsin. Lihtsalt Ee Locations
Õpetaja: View. See on ka Niukene trikk, Mida te saate kasutada, et natukene kui te refaktureerite midagi ja te tahate. Ma kutsun seda Sanithy Check,
Õpetaja: eks? On see, et sa justkui Tegelikult usaldad tööriista Eriti. Jaavas on ju? Aga kui sa muudad mingisuguse asja ära, siis sa võid alati korra lihtsalt huvi pärast otsida, kui tekstina üle projekti
Õpetaja: Kas sa leiad kuskilt niukest asja Ja sa saad selle panna juurde ka, et näed Kui sa. Otsid, siis palun jälgige Vaata
Õpetaja: vaikimisi. Ta otsib lihtsalt sõna. Locations View. Kui sa ütled, et. Ja Match the Case,
Õpetaja: no siis ta vaatab seda ka Match the World. Siis ta vaatab, et sõna otseses mõttes sõnana on üks niuke asi, et ta ei ole nagu mingi liitekst kuskil, vaid sõnana nii öelda. Era eraldi Sõnana on niuksed tööriistad. On teil siin ka?
Õpetaja: No for the Love ka. Nüüd on see asi läbi. Ee, tahaks liikuda. Edasi Panen siia. Feb. Kümme.
Õpetaja: Committent bussh ja. Kui Midagi tuleb pärast välja siis, savisaare ei ole päris arendus boss, Aa.
Õpetaja: Töötas, Küsin, Ära Ee, pussis ära. Jah,
Õpetaja: ee, see, ee. See ei läinudki kuhugi.
Õpetaja: See läheb Ee, komponentsisse. Nüüd.
Õpetaja: Good Spot, siia.
Õpetaja: Ee, ikka. Pean oma nagu mitte otsa tegema. Nüüd siin.
Õpetaja: Ee, aa, ma Vaatan, oota.
Õpetaja: Ja kui piinlik on see? Kui nüüd on veel midagi vaja kommit Ida, siis on nagu.
Õpetaja: Ja teil ei ole mõtet sellele harule järgi tulla või? No, kui te tahate võita seda teha, sest et ma niikuinii mörsin selle ära kohe
Õpetaja: niiöelda Masterisse ja siis kustutan selle haru ära.
Õpetaja: Jätan endale alles niukse asja nagu õpetaja video Üks, et kui ma teen Täna Scripti video Ühe järgi, siis ma teen niimoodi, et ta koodi vaatab. Onju, et
Õpetaja: selles etapis, mis oli fridi Cleveron,
Õpetaja: nii mis on vaja teha, minna selle haru peale.
Õpetaja: Aa, kuhu lähed? Alati Võibolla mingi päris elus. Vaatad, et Mastar on joonel, või mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis Lähed õpetaja Checkout?
Õpetaja: Ütlen, õpetaja Feb. Kümme see. Koht on kus tõmbad alati pidurit ja loed
Õpetaja: merge Feb. Kümme Into. Master yes
Õpetaja: Nüüd. Ta. Peaks küsima, et eliitõpetaja Feb Kümme sul
Õpetaja: sa. Võid tulla järgi sest, et see on mul kohalik haru
Õpetaja: sa. Sest, sa lähed remoodi vastu
Õpetaja: Ja kui ma nüüd seda vajutan, näete. Ta ütles siin, et kustuta kohalikke, nüüd mis ta pakub.
Õpetaja: No seda ma veel ei kustutas,
Õpetaja: mitte Sõnumit saad tagantjärgi muuta. Või?
Õpetaja: Ee, ee. Mingisuguste käskudega on see kindlasti võimalik. Jah, aga mitte nagu läbi Tööriista
Õpetaja: peaks olema, aga kui ta On sul arvutis? On suht lihtne. Kui ta on pilves siis juba võiks keerulisem Aga peaks. Olema peaks olema võimalik seal ka. Ma olen Suht kindel, et saab?
Õpetaja: Lihtsalt On vaja mingisugust ee, niiöelda käsku mida küsida. Vanasti oleks kuskilt ajanud siis internetist jälgida. Lihtsalt küsid Chatilt, vaata, et mul on Niukene sõnum ja
Õpetaja: saab muuta, Et sa ei ole rahul, Et sul on mitu korda
Õpetaja: ei ole midagi. Ärge unustage ära vaata, et ega ega ma võin öelda, aga teie enda harud on ka kained prügikasti kauplemis,
Õpetaja: et, ee, mis meil lõpuks on, siis kui Te hakkate projekte tegema, Siis mis teid huvitab, on see, mis iganes see minu lõplik versioon.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui te tahate vaadata nagu mingisuguseid ee, Näiteid ja asju,
Õpetaja: et lõpus on tegelikult üstnaspuha. Aga kui tahad näiteks koju jätta mingit haru ja vaadata hiljem järgi, siis oleks nagu teine teema juba
Õpetaja: kellel seda aega on, eksole?
Õpetaja: Aa, kuulge, aga äkki oleks see paras koht kus teha. Üldse ka paus.
Õpetaja: Kas ma nüüd võin ära kustutada selle Track Brunch I.
Õpetaja: Nüüd läheb kustutamisse. See ka
Õpetaja: nii Bushina oma ja näete enda Masteris, et see on teie enda arvutis, Teil peaks ka olema roheline nooleke,
Õpetaja: push. Ige see alati ära. Kui näete nooli, mis te peate tegema, peab noolid nooli. Siis
Õpetaja: ee. Teeme siis pausi. Ja kas siis põrutame, kuni lõpuni sobib?
Õpetaja: Ma panen siis pausile ka. Või siis peab hoidma meeles. Ee, et ei unusta.
Õpetaja: Nii.
Õpetaja: Screenshare vist oli juba peal. Või? Ei olnud ma igal pool.
Õpetaja: No vaatame järgmise taski. Ee, pangaauto pangaauti tabel. See vaade.
Õpetaja: Ee, sai tehtud, Tõstame siia siia.
Õpetaja: No, Reede, Oleme nüüd teinud kõvasti
Õpetaja: Jälle On siin mingisugune pilt Vaikimisi
Õpetaja: kole. Asi võtab lihtsalt esimese pildi ja paneb selle My Space iks.
Õpetaja: No mis kuradi teadsus Seal ma ei saa aru nii.
Õpetaja: Ee. Pangaautomaadi asukoha lisamine.
Õpetaja: Lisa, uus asukohavaade.
Õpetaja: Tuleb Üks uus link
Õpetaja: uus. Vaata Komponent Location View aadressil. Kaldkriips Location Loovenüüsse. Ka vastav linkedinägu. Asukoht, mida kuvatakse vaid siis kui kasutaja. Kes sisse logis on Admin, Ahah,
Õpetaja: Lisa juurde. Tekst. Lisaasukoht. See on see niimoodi. Ee, kasuta eraldi komponente.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle faili. Tegelikult ma nimetaks Forms iks.
Õpetaja: Aa, kasuta erinevaid Aa komponente, et näete, nagu et see lõpuks hakkab Aa niimoodi kokku mängima. Siin on üks tuttav komponent, Mis komponent on? Tuttav
Õpetaja: City Strop Down Jee, taaskasutus peagi midagi progema.
Õpetaja: Bla bla, bla, blabla. Ee. Ja nüüd siin Asi läheb natukene niiöelda. Aa, over insineerimiseks. Selles mõttes, et Me tahame ainult õppida.
Õpetaja: Nimelt, mida on see, et päriselus? Ma ei teeks elu sees nendest
Õpetaja: asjadest. Siin eraldi komponente, neid väikseid tükke
Õpetaja: seal ei ole Point I. Need on nii väiksed asjad. Aga ma olen need sellegipoolest selles ülesandes teinud, et tekiks selline asi nagu Grand
Õpetaja: Grand Children ja Grand Parent.
Õpetaja: See siin on vanem.
Õpetaja: See on tema laps.
Õpetaja: See roheline on tema laps ja see punane siin. See Atm image on tema laps.
Õpetaja: Kes on need lapselapsed?
Õpetaja: Ma olen seda sellepärast teinud. Et, Ee, oleks meil ka võimalik harjutada niukest olukorda, sest päriselu rakendustest on kindlasti seda olukorda, et on nagu veel rohkem leiereid,
Õpetaja: et asju pannakse kokku ja asjad on palju sügavamad, kui ainult kaks kihti, täiesti reaalne.
Õpetaja: Sest et kui meil andmed peavad hakkama siin voolama alla,
Õpetaja: siis nüüd nad ei voolu ühe korruse alla, vaid me peame tegema et Asjad voolavad lausa kaks korrust alla.
Õpetaja: Ja veelgi tähtsam, Kui meil hakkavad mingid sündmused toimuma, siis Me soovime et
Õpetaja: need sündmused hakkavad ülesse lendama Lausa kaks korrust et siis on teil süntaks, on ka ja see teadmine ja oskus ja kogemus. Siin on liigne tehniline keerukus
Õpetaja: aga see Ongi selle liigse tehnil tehnilise keerukuse enda pärast.
Õpetaja: Me võime teha ka ainult, et on üks korrus
Õpetaja: Where is the fun in that onju
Õpetaja: Aa, et ee, reaalne elu on kindlasti midagi muud.
Õpetaja: Olete nõus? Teeme liigse keerukuse.
Õpetaja: Noh, taas ka nii ette näinud. Kas me saame taaskiga Vaielda
Õpetaja: taaskasutaja. Aa, selle Ma nimetaks ümber. Location details.
Õpetaja: Form Vorm
Õpetaja: image Input on Ee, natukene sushi ee. Ma vist ei paneks seda vormile külge. Ma jätaks ta sellest
Õpetaja: vormist välja. Nad Väljad jäetakse ainult
Õpetaja: kuidagi taolist veits. Nagu Muudan taaski siin jooksul.
Õpetaja: Ee location name input number of Input transaction type, checkbox, bla, bla, blaa,
Õpetaja: transaction. Type checkbox Andmed saadakse teenusega. Kett Atm transaction. Types
Õpetaja: raha sisse Raha välja makse. Algväärtused Falls. Algväärtused Tikpoksid on väljas, bla, bla, bla, bla.
Õpetaja: Kasuta komponent. Image input. Ma annan selle teile eelmisest kursusest. Ma ei tea see mis siin veits olla.
Õpetaja: Seal oli lihtsalt üks niukene eriline koodijupp, mida ma ei näe, Point I, et seda läbi kirjutada. Me võime seda läbi rääkida, et mis seal? Nagu toimub.
Õpetaja: Kui vajutad valipilti, et mis on nagu. Kuidas see töötab
Õpetaja: Ee, kuvapilti komponendiga Atm Image Voe eraldi komponent pildi Vaatamiseks,
Õpetaja: mis toimib all järgnevalt. Ma ei tea, kas see kirjeldus on ka
Õpetaja: Kui pildi info on all või tühistrind, siis kuvada default Vaikimisi pilti arusaadav. Pole pilti valinud,
Õpetaja: aga midagi võiks Kuvada.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma vaatan, Kas balsamik on mu siin kuskil veel elujõuline, Ee, oma
Õpetaja: õigesuse kohta ka veel. Vaata, tühi, täidetud
Õpetaja: tühi. Vaadake siis Pilti on ju täidetav.
Õpetaja: Kui valid pildi, siis seda pilti kuvatakse. Äkki Ma valisin vale pildi.
Õpetaja: Kas ma valisin faili nime järgi pildi? Või oli mul seal Explorer is, et näitab ikoone vaid ma nagu näen enamvähem, mida ma Valin. Tahaks su tagasisidet. Lisa veel ei ole toimunud, onju?
Õpetaja: Komponendid raamidega.
Õpetaja: Kui pilt on valitud, siis kuvada valitud pilti valitades nuppu, tagasi. Suunatakse Kasutaja tagasi vaatajale Atm Sla Le
Õpetaja: Nupule Lisavajuutades kogutakse lehelt kokku vajalikud andmed ning saadetakse enam. Ei olegi ket host.
Õpetaja: Ostita isa post Atma Okei ja
Õpetaja: appi, Popid.
Õpetaja: Jah, mul on apiga kohe üks. Ee, vahva lugu.
Õpetaja: Ma Ei, tea, kas ma räägin mitte.
Õpetaja: Äkki näitab mind halvas Valguses.
Õpetaja: Ma võin rääkida. Ükskord kõndisime siis kuskil, Ee, seal Kristiine lähedal.
Õpetaja: Ja seal oli üks mees ja naine, kes tülitsesid omavahel
Õpetaja: ja mina, Minu üks sõber kunagi vanasti õpetas mulle seda. Vaata, et kui sa nagu näed mingeid tülitsevaid inimesi,
Õpetaja: ära mine Vahele.
Õpetaja: Sa ei tea Backstoori. Sa ei tea mitte midagi. Sa ei tea, kuidas see sinule lõpeb. Its Not Worth It
Õpetaja: Ja. Ma Arvan et, tal on õigus
Õpetaja: mina. Mu naine siis jalutasime ühel pool teed ja teisel pool teed oli üks naine,
Õpetaja: Ee mees. Ja Selgelt oli Ta paarike
Õpetaja: meenutas natukene. Noh, Rekording on sees vä?
Õpetaja: Natuke mu õde ja kunagi tema ühte eksi.
Õpetaja: Kogu tülitsesid samal viisil armukadega inimesed
Õpetaja: ühesõnaga midagi. Nad tülitsesid. Vaata ja Siis see naine. Nagu niimoodi. Vaikselt Appi, Tulge appi,
Õpetaja: naine. Nagu vaatasime üle poole ja ma ütlesin, ta ütles, et kapi kappi tulge kappi
Õpetaja: No Ei, taha kappi. Minna.
Õpetaja: Pärast lüüakse kappi mind.
Õpetaja: Ee, ei, see seal ei olnud midagi eluohtlikult kindlat, et, ee, ma arvan, et ta jäi elama.
Õpetaja: Võibolla,
Õpetaja: ee. Ei maksa igale poole oma nina torkida. Kusjuures mu naine aastaid hiljem on öelnud, et Rainsul on täielikult õigus.
Õpetaja: Siit Sealt oled kuulnud lugusid? Vot siin alles. Üks inimene sai nuga, kui mingi mölakas ütles müüjale midagi halvasti ja siis teine klient, nagu kutsus korrale, et. Kuule, kuidas te nagu räägite müüjaga? Nagu, et. Et, noh, ebaviisakas
Õpetaja: läks, välja. Sai nuga, suri ära.
Õpetaja: Noh, no jah, ilmselt töödes ka appi ja teisisõnus teda pekstakse kappi. Praegult lihtsalt on veel. No aga
Õpetaja: nii, lähme edasi.
Õpetaja: Aa,
Õpetaja: ahah, ee. Nupule lisavajutades kogutakse andmed kokku Ja saadetakse Location sõnumiga õnnestunud sõnumi puhul resetida kõik väljad ja kuvata hea teadet. Asukoht lisatud. No selle jaoks eraldi komponent, mis võtab sisse Propsi message.
Õpetaja: Kui Alerti ei kuvata. Kui on mingi sisu, siis kuvatakse. No niuke, roheline heaolukorrad. Täida kõik väljad
Õpetaja: ja tuleb vastus sellise nimega Pangaautomaat teaduse kohta on juba süsteemis olemas, Sest et front seda ju kuidagi ei tea.
Õpetaja: Enne asukoha postitamist on vajalik kontrollida, et kohustuslikud väljed on täidetud linna asukoht, automaatide arv ja vähemalt üks Transaction Type on valitud. Vähemalt üks Checkbox on Selected.
Õpetaja: Kui midagi on täitmata, siis tuleb kasutajat selles osas teavitada sõnumiga, et täida kõik väljad. Nõuete kohaselt
Õpetaja: sama asukoha asukohaga ei tohiks lisada. Furbiden Neli null, kolm
Õpetaja: ah? Sama asukohta ei tohiks saada lisada. Ee, tundub, et ma olen ka veits väsind. Juba
Õpetaja: Kui on forbiide. Neli null. Kolm, siis Ee, error, Kood kolm Kolm, Noh, Panen siia. Ka selle väikse täienduse
Õpetaja: ja error kood välja väärt.
Õpetaja: Kell läks paigast ära.
Õpetaja: Mitte suus, vaid arvutis.
Õpetaja: Error, koodvälja väärtus.
Õpetaja: On kolm, kolm, kolm.
Õpetaja: Võibolla selle siit niimoodi välja.
Õpetaja: Siis võtab message väljalt.
Õpetaja: Ee, väljalt Vastaa veateade
Õpetaja: Sellise nimega Pangaautomaadi asukoht on juba süsteemis olemas kõigi teiste vigade puhul suunata. Kasutaja vaatele kaldkriips, error.
Õpetaja: No mingi pildi Said ta vast ette. Ee võib juba saamikuga ka, vaadata, et et on tühi
Õpetaja: sõnumit Backendile Get Cities.
Õpetaja: Seda ei olnud taskis kirjas, aga tegelikult, ee. Noh, see võiks seal kirjas olla,
Õpetaja: sest et seda See komponent on ainult vaatekomponent. Komponent Ise ei saa andmeid. Talle tuleb need anda.
Õpetaja: Ee, sõnum Backendile. Aa, get ei teinud transaction. Types saad andmed. Need tulevad siit.
Õpetaja: Aa sisseraha. Väljamaksed.
Õpetaja: Id, Id Force Force, täidetud.
Õpetaja: Kui kõik. On täidetud, vajutad lisa nuppu läheb teele, Boss, sõnum, esimest korda läheb sõnum kaasa. Küsime andmeid
Õpetaja: või niimoodi Saada sõnum. Vaataksin, mis asi on Request Body.
Õpetaja: Mis need on?
Õpetaja: Sponspody ja Sponspody Sponsor. Punkt, Tata sponsor, punkt, tata.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on nagu teistsugune olukord, et hoopis Request Body peab minema. Niukene sõnum, võimalikud staatused ja asjad
Õpetaja: on kellegil Mingeid küsimusi?
Õpetaja: Just mitte.
Õpetaja: No tuleb lihtsalt alustada. Kust kohast algusest?
Õpetaja: Ee, no, uus asukohavaade location.
Õpetaja: Millest me alustame? Muidugi, uus branš V. Üksteist On see.
Õpetaja: No New Branch.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: uus vaatekomponent. Location View aadressil Caldkriips Location.
Õpetaja: Mis me teeme siis?
Õpetaja: Uus vaade, parem klõps ja kogu aeg on panend ja oli Location View
Õpetaja: Location view Vaade bla, bla, bla,
Õpetaja: Selle kõige lihtsam on korra nüüd kokku. Tõmmata Niimoodi siit styleblokile, saadame Pensionile
Õpetaja: script. I tõmbame kokku ja tõstame selle ühe siia ülesse.
Õpetaja: Aa, okei Noolekene vilgub.
Õpetaja: Mis me teeme, Ei, hakka Tv I tegema. Vaid Läheb kohe.
Õpetaja: Mida?
Õpetaja: Mm, uuds tuleb.
Õpetaja: Shortcut. Iga, kuhu ta maandub.
Õpetaja: Reed, vana hea, Üks rida, kolm.
Õpetaja: Noh Munes juba võib näha seda koodi
Õpetaja: Kirjutaks selle peast ka valmis, kui vaja.
Õpetaja: No Ütleme niiöelda, et Las jääb, siis esialgu lihtsalt üks veerg.
Õpetaja: Midagi taolist.
Õpetaja: Ei, no ma võin sealt kõrvale jätta. Kuigi mis siin ikka väga vaadata on. Ma ei tea
Õpetaja: ee, Vaatame sinna Taaski siis. Ee, vaade on tehtud, aga nüüd See, et ta siis
Õpetaja: reageeriks. Kaldkriips Location, Mis me tegema? Peame Ruter Luteri indeks.
Õpetaja: Otsime üles ja indeks.
Õpetaja: No võtame siit alt lihtsalt ee, järjekorrast. Järgmise võtke koos selle komaga niimoodi. Üks reavahetus ka. Control D,
Õpetaja: Login,
Õpetaja: Login Root.
Õpetaja: See osa nüüd kõige tähtsam et tuleb ära kustutada,
Õpetaja: Mis on need kaks tähte, mida võiks vajutada?
Õpetaja: Suured,
Õpetaja: Okei, ma testisin. Kas te olete üleval inimesed?
Õpetaja: Okei, you bast a test.
Õpetaja: Tublid olete Võibolla mõtlesin, et kõik oma asjad kokku. Ja Minge, koju. Aga näed Irit
Õpetaja: Lv? Ei, jah, jah, aga siit on vaja nüüd valida õige asi, onju?
Õpetaja: Näe, siin ruut on ikka vale.
Õpetaja: Tunnistan ülesse, et ma päriselt ka testisin.
Õpetaja: Nii, vaatame, tuli see ülesse. Import ka No tundub, et tuli
Õpetaja: siis praegult juba Tegelikult saaks testida selles mõttes, et, ee. Minna lihtsalt rakenduses siia Location
Õpetaja: ja tuleb see üks kolumn ette, mis seal, on onju?
Õpetaja: Okei, Ee, mis edasi?
Õpetaja: Homme nüüd selle vastava linkima ka asukoht.
Õpetaja: Ahah, navigatsiooni menüüst räägib.
Õpetaja: Paneks selle sõna juurde siia navigatsiooni menüüsse ka vastav link. Asukoht,
Õpetaja: mida kohatakse vaid siis, kui kasutaja, kes sisseloris on. Admin Lisa juurde. Heeder tekst.
Õpetaja: Lisa asukoht.
Õpetaja: Ahah. See heeder tekst.
Õpetaja: Ma pakun, et teeme samamoodi. Vaata, et see ongi selles esimeses rohus. See heeder teksti nimi oli.
Õpetaja: Ee, H Üks ja, ee, liisa asukoht.
Õpetaja: Võibolla lihtsalt siin. Natukene Aitan seda niimoodi, et teeme ta.
Õpetaja: Teeme ta korra, Teeme ta ära.
Õpetaja: Mulle meeldi see. Mulle ei meeldi need Eesti ülaka Omajad hullult tahavad närvi.
Õpetaja: Poolteist on olemas. Noh, saab kontrollida ka Algus on tehtud
Õpetaja: Ee kasuta eraldi komponente.
Õpetaja: Ma korra täiendan taaski ka. Vaata, siin ei ole andmete kohta. Vaata, andmed päri.
Õpetaja: Get.
Õpetaja: Kaldkriips.
Õpetaja: Api. Kaldkriip City S. Oli vist, on ju?
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: Noh, kuidagi nii
Õpetaja: Kui me vaatame nüüd seda setup, I võiks juba vaikselt sellega tegeleda. Mis Meil on vaja teha. Nüüd.
Õpetaja: Mis mõtted on?
Õpetaja: No rohkem? Vihjeid ei peagi andma.
Õpetaja: Tead, niimoodi
Õpetaja: Kolm kolumnit. Aga enne seda kuus. Rau, Onju, See siin on Ro üks. See kogu kupats on ro kaks,
Õpetaja: Ta on laiska. Ee, Näete, kus see rou algab ja lõpeb. Kas kellegil on? Muidu Ren ei ole värvitud? On Kõik kollane ka
Õpetaja: Jah, Sul tasub ikkagi See plugin Rainbow Plugin ära tõmmata.
Õpetaja: Kuidas sul on see olemas juba,
Õpetaja: Aga tegelikult kõigil peaks olema ju tasuta
Õpetaja: ta ei Või on mingid ekstra funktsioonid? Okei,
Õpetaja: võtke see Row niimoodi ja tehke tublike.
Õpetaja: Aa, Kui ei ole kindel, siis võib teha niimoodi, et tõmmake Lihtsalt rohu pealt kokku ja siit
Õpetaja: üks roov juurde.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, siia. Ajutiselt võib panna korra mingi
Õpetaja: esimesse. Veergu tuleb. Mis asi tuleb?
Õpetaja: Panen City. S tuleb. Ta on lasta hetkel olla
Õpetaja: ja nüüd on tähtis aru saada, et selle Roses. Meil tuleb kokku kolm kolumnit. Onju, et jällegi Võite kokku niimoodi kokku lasta. Kui
Õpetaja: olla siin real. Ja ma olen kontrolltublikeid jälle kokku võtta,
Õpetaja: peab tulema kolm kolum It siia sisse. On Nii,
Õpetaja: ee, Nüüd selle teise võib lahti teha. Ja City S asemel. Siia tuleb vorm Ja viimasesse tuleb pilt
Õpetaja: saate võttes aru et meil On nagu
Õpetaja: juba vaikselt. Nagu mingisugune See ka.
Õpetaja: Aa, mida tükk aega ei ole teinud. Aga selle eelmisele roule mis on see, kus on Heeder võiks öelda ka. Margin Bottom ja kolm
Õpetaja: Mv. Kolm.
Õpetaja: No muidu liiga seljas elab eelmises kohas. Me just unustasime seda teha.
Õpetaja: Kiire paranduse võib teha. Mis asi me ennem tegime? Just Atms. Vio on ju
Õpetaja: Co Ro sisse panna? Ka Mb. Kolm.
Õpetaja: Rohkem roosi meil vist ei olnud seal kui kaks rauda oli, onju?
Õpetaja: No, See oleks nagu mingi enam vähem ühtne, nagu mingi.
Õpetaja: Aga nende asjade kaugus Ee, see oli Sisselogimine.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd oleks vaja linki ka. Tegelikult, Ee, siia ülesse saada saaks. Seda Me ei peaks panema ise siit niimoodi ülevalt, mis ma Panin ennem Location, onju?
Õpetaja: Kus asuvad lingid, Kus asub navigatsiooni menüü, Navbar, Kus navaar asub?
Õpetaja: Aa Poe
Õpetaja: on
Õpetaja: Vot See nüüd Ee. Wf East login. Näita ka sisselogimist.
Õpetaja: Meil nüüd juhtub selline olukord, kus me soovime handlida. Seda, et. Ee, oota siin. Oli veel eraldi reegel oli ka veel Tegelikult Siin oli Niukene reegel. Me võime ühe rooterlingi juurde teha. Seal, Koh,
Õpetaja: ee. Teeme sellest pangaautomaadist. Teeme Dublikaadi.
Õpetaja: Ja Paneme selle nimeks, Oota, mis siin taaskis oli kirjas asukoht. Lihtsalt
Õpetaja: Davai. Teeme nii. Control k Ee, üksteist.
Õpetaja: Ee, Working progress. Üks kui mitte ainult boss,
Õpetaja: kui Keegi teine, nagu Ee mõtles ka seda järgi tulemist. Ja siis tehke kõik korraga ära.
Õpetaja: Võite juba roll back ida või ma ei tea, kas Te kasutate Scripti või Mitte Võite küll fetsida. Nüüd
Õpetaja: me tegime ka mingi skili, onju? Mis Skill meil oli?
Õpetaja: Kasutab seda. Keegi Location Video on Selline kõik lahti teha. Aga
Õpetaja: põhimõtteliselt. Meil on üks raug. Kus on üks kolm ise Asukoht.
Õpetaja: See on teine rohu. Kus on Kolm kolumit
Õpetaja: pärast hakkame Timmima nende mingeid suurusi. Asju, et hetkel nagu see on Savi
Õpetaja: käsi püsti, Kes veel tuleb alles järgi, Okei, ootame üldse on,
Õpetaja: et, ee, ei näe. Õpetaja teeb ühte teist Ee, remoodi alla, Ah, ilmas.
Õpetaja: Nii.
Õpetaja: Kas nüüd võib edasi liikuda või ootame kedagi?
Õpetaja: Hea küll,
Õpetaja: hakkame selle Citysega pihta. Ma oleks siia nii öelda. Oi, h. Nelja sisse ei taha panna, et see on nagu
Õpetaja: siia asemele, Kui meil on mingi komponent juba olemas, siis kuidas me seda saame? Kasutada
Õpetaja: Nägime, et tegelikult teeb suht edukalt kogu töö meile ära.
Õpetaja: Mida Me Tahame siia,
Õpetaja: mida me tahame. Siia ei lisaasukoht on juba meil olemas. Siin Näed, lisaasukoht.
Õpetaja: Ee, nüüd samm sammult. Me soovime kasutada siit Vasakult paremale minnes.
Õpetaja: See osa siin Tahame. Mida see on meil olemas.
Õpetaja: Siis siia, mis ma kirjutan?
Õpetaja: Tahame Kasutada seda klotsi ja suurte tähtedega Cd.
Õpetaja: Kas Cd või Cd?
Õpetaja: City Strop Down. Valik Et Tab. Tema ei tea, Teeks talle paarilise niiöelda Tag I, aga meie soovime seda Hetkel ainult üksikuna. Üksik tagina tuleb päev, kui me
Õpetaja: soovime teistsugust lähenemist.
Õpetaja: Nii
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: nüüd. Ee. City Strop, Ta on ootab ee, kahte asja sisse.
Õpetaja: Ta ootab. Aa, ma näen praegu, et üks väike viga Tema on tüübiks kui objekt.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta taustal töötabki on ka objekt, aga Mis on veel täpsem, kuidas siia tulla? Hoidke korra kontrollid peal.
Õpetaja: Pärast võtab äkiga liikuda, tagasi.
Õpetaja: Et Ee, siia. Ei taha öelda, et Citys on lihtsalt objekt, Vaid hoopis on massiiv.
Õpetaja: Kuidas see mul silma paistis? Oligi Praegult sellest samast kohast,
Õpetaja: et ma tahtsin vaadata, et mida ta sisse võtab, Ta ootab.
Õpetaja: Näed Massiivi objektidest ja Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: Nüüd need andmed. Me peamegi saama jälle siia.
Õpetaja: Aa, võibolla Hästi, natukene Cheat Ime
Õpetaja: Databloki Teeme ära, aga sisu. Läheme. Rotime ära. Atm is vihust natukene. Lähme teeme ühe lihtsamaks.
Õpetaja: Meil on siin name olemas. Meil on Komponents Mida me siin kasutame
Õpetaja: No mis me siia juurde tahame teha? Mis bloki me tahame teha?
Õpetaja: Absoluutselt ei taha veel seda teha.
Õpetaja: Ma Pigem keskendun sellele, et ta ootab mingeid sisendeid. Päeva lõpuks peab siia sisse voolama. City s objekt ja Selected City Id objekt.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis. Ma tahan, nagu siin öelda niimoodi, et te panete siia.
Õpetaja: Control Tühik. Selected City Id taotab väärtust Citys. Ta ootab väärtust.
Õpetaja: No kust nad tulevad.
Õpetaja: Noh, kust saad tulla? Need väärtused siia Templetisse. Järsku dünaamiliselt.
Õpetaja: Ta soovib andmeid, andmeid.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja neid andmeid anda,
Õpetaja: et kuskil andmeid hoida, siis on vaja mida Noh, databloki? Mille jaoks siit on vahe?
Õpetaja: Sest meil on seal objektid, kus on andmed, aga me saame ainult suhelda läbi siltida.
Õpetaja: Noh, aidake teie mul kirjutada. Aa, Data on oma olemuselt ei ole.
Õpetaja: Jah, aga me võime praegu öelda lihtsalt meetod siis ta nagu jaavaga klapib.
Õpetaja: Aga Muidu ta on funktsioon. Data on oma olemuselt funktsioon.
Õpetaja: See Siin on nimi Lihtsalt Data, Mis siis peale nime tuleb.
Õpetaja: Aa, ei olnud Punkte ei tule.
Õpetaja: Kui sa kirjutad mingeid meetodit. Do something. No siis tuleb sulud
Õpetaja: ühtegi parameetrit. Ei, tule. Aga see Võimalus oleks, Mis siis järgnev meetodil?
Õpetaja: Jah, lageliselt suruda, et see on koodi ulatus.
Õpetaja: Data on oma olemuselt funktsioon või meetod, mis tagastab andme Objekti andmemudeli objekti, mis tagastab tõrn.
Õpetaja: No kuidas me saame nüüd seda objekti tekitada?
Õpetaja: Jah, nüüd ei ole küsimuski, et missugused sildikesed meil siin peavad olema.
Õpetaja: Meil peavad olema sildikene Citys ja Selected City Id. Sest et kui Propsides on nad siin niimoodi juba selliste nimedega kasutatud, miks Peaksime me siis selles datablokis mingid muud nimed välja mõtlema.
Õpetaja: Ee selle Citysega on siis see, et ta on massiiv mingisugustest objektidest.
Õpetaja: Ee, minu Mõte on, see et kiirendame oma tööd natukene ja läheme. Teeme lahti. Atm, mis viu? Ja Lähme lihtsalt võtame sealt need
Õpetaja: need sildikesed koos mudeliga ära, et meil on see vaev juba tehtud.
Õpetaja: Vaata, Citys on siin, on nii?
Õpetaja: Ja Selected City on siin üleval, et põhimõtteliselt võiks Võta niimoodi. Lausa on nii
Õpetaja: Copida need ja siis tuleme lihtsalt siia
Õpetaja: Location View alla ja paneme need plöraqi maha,
Õpetaja: kui me siia maandume sellele lehele nii öelda. Lisa uus asukoht. Siis me tegelikult soovimegi, et esiteks on valik. Vali linn, onju
Õpetaja: või? Kõik linnad vist. Mis seal Valik on. Ma ei mäletagi. Jah.
Õpetaja: Mhmh.
Õpetaja: Võibolla me teeme hästi natuke taaski väliselt Seda ümber. Mul praegu üks mõte tuli. Põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: siis ma Teeksin hästi natuke teistmoodi.
Õpetaja: Okei, lähme edasi
Õpetaja: nüüd.
Õpetaja: Meil on vaja siduda, niimoodi et sinna sellesse City Strop Town I Lähevadki siis need andmed alla. Ma ei tea, Oota korra. Mis järjekorras nad siin on? Citys on kõigepealt. Ja siis tuleb Selected City
Õpetaja: aga ma just isegi tõstaks nad siin ka ümber, nagu niimoodi
Õpetaja: mingi City tuleb valida. Ja see need on andmed. Või on teistpidi just loogilisem? Ma ei tea ka See Niukene.
Õpetaja: Sellise järjekorras. Ma pigem ma vaatan, kuidas me seda siia välja kutsusime. S, et mis järjekorras? Me panime need kõigepealt City S Ja siis Selected City Id. Las siis jääb sellesse järjekorda. Aga siin teeme samamoodi.
Õpetaja: Kustutame selle Selected City Id ära.
Õpetaja: Nii Kõigepealt me peame andma alla andmed. Mis iganes on meil Citys sees, ehk me ütleme siin lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Ahah, mis on puudu? Mõtleb, et tahan anda lihtsalt mingit Stringi vool on ka.
Õpetaja: Kool on siia ja nüüd hakkad Citys kirjutama. Siis ta pakub seda muutujat Kontrolltöö
Õpetaja: Selected City Id mõlemad. Ee, niiöelda Syntaxid töötavad Kas Camel Case?
Õpetaja: Ee, või siis ee. Kebab Aga et anda just märku, et tegemist on Propsiga
Õpetaja: Ropsi nimega, siis on mõeldud, Et pigem kasutada seda. Jällegi oleks võinud panna kooloni kohe ka
Õpetaja: ja temalt. Siis tuleb need andmed voolavad. Nüüd on kõik samamoodi. Anna lihtsalt sisu ja ütle see, et mida tuleb valida, ongi kõik.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: okei,
Õpetaja: ee, nüüd on Siis see. Vaata, et kui me praegu siia lehele läheks, siis on siin ainult see kõik linnad on olemas. Ülejäänud on tühjus.
Õpetaja: No üks tühi rida on. See on tegelikult see sama tühi objekt. Põhimõtteliselt. Noh, kui siia paneks mingi
Õpetaja: siis ta oleks.
Õpetaja: See on see väike väärtus. Aga me peame nagu taaskis öeldakse nüüd ka, et Andmed, päri. Back end ilt.
Õpetaja: No nüüd, meil on vaja andmeid pärida. Mis mõtted siin on?
Õpetaja: Aga kui ma ütlen, üldse, on vaja mingeid andmeid pärida. Mida see eeldab Access viusse. Seda küll
Õpetaja: mudel. Meil on juba, et üldse saaks midagi kirjutada. Koodi, mis meil on? Vaja,
Õpetaja: Annan Väikseid vihjeid, mis on vaja.
Õpetaja: Me tahame käivitada mingisugust tegevust üldse. Nagu. Kuidas saab tegevust kirjutada Koodis meetod,
Õpetaja: Kus ma praegu meetodi saaks Kirjutada Noh,
Õpetaja: Ei, saagi. Miks, mis meil puudu on?
Õpetaja: No, Adrian ütles kõva häälega. Ma räägin seda.
Õpetaja: Sa ütlesid juba Selle vastuse Vist vist Jah, Ongi jah,
Õpetaja: et meil on olemas name. Meil on components. Meil on tata, aga meil puudub metsad koma siia ja
Õpetaja: ehk toots.
Õpetaja: See tähendab Meid loots,
Õpetaja: nii et neid võib olla palju. Siis on nad kuskile vahele vaja panna. Ta algus ja lõpp,
Õpetaja: Kui eesmärk on datablokki tuua, Ära meetod,
Õpetaja: Get Cities. Teatud siin. Me teeme ka veits kiiremat tööd.
Õpetaja: Võtame selle meetodi sealt sellest Atm sujust ja et me, nagu see ei anna mingit lisaväärtust, Kui me täpselt sama asja uuesti läbi harjutame.
Õpetaja: Kus on see Ee, Get Cities
Õpetaja: ja tasub võtta. Aga Pange tähele See meetod kutsub abi. Meetodeid, onju, et see need mõlemad tuleb võtta.
Õpetaja: Nad on tervik praegult.
Õpetaja: Vaata, kui tähtis on see, et nad on Nagu üksteise nii öelda, seda ei ole vaja, võtta, sest see ei asugi siin. See asub kuskil Navigation Services, onju?
Õpetaja: Aga see kood põhimõtteliselt on kõik, mis meil on vaja.
Õpetaja: Copy. Ärge nüüd seda katki keset. Jumala eest, siin on seda ka vaja.
Õpetaja: Ühesõnaga paneme siia kuskil siia alla poole. Tahaks, et tuleks siia Kuhugi. Ma ei tea, nüüd
Õpetaja: see kõik võiks töötada.
Õpetaja: Ta Näitab, et keegi kutsub seda välja, aga ma Mõtlen, et see sinine värv ei peegelda tõtt praegult,
Õpetaja: kus me tahame seda meetodit välja kutsuda.
Õpetaja: Millal me tahame mu küsimust niimoodi
Õpetaja: siia lehele, Millal me tahame kutsuda välja, et too ära. Andmed kohe kohe, siis kolmkümmend Before Mount,
Õpetaja: et jällegi tõmbame kokku. Vaata, see on eraldi Voeblokk Siin ei ole praegu
Õpetaja: loogiline koht. Oleks kuskile metsad sisse panna peale seda Before Mount,
Õpetaja: et enne kui hakkad siin üldse midagi tilvendama, tooks Võibolla andmed ära.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd siin Before Mount Is. Me tahamegi käivitada seda Get Cityst, mis Ma kirjutan siia.
Õpetaja: Tubli desket Cities.
Õpetaja: Ja ah Need surud ka.
Õpetaja: No ja nüüd juba vist peaks olema niimoodi. Et tulete siia.
Õpetaja: On olemas.
Õpetaja: No see on natukene valikute küsimus, aga
Õpetaja: tehniliselt võttes. Ma tahaksin anda sellele aa natukene võimekust juurde selles osas, et mis mulle ei. Meeldi. Mis te arvate, mis mul tegelt ei meeldi? Vaata korra, kuidas siin on üldse siin Pole ühtegi näidist niiöelda. Kõik on juba. Tallinn on valitud.
Õpetaja: Aga mis võiks olla teistmoodi
Õpetaja: just selle juures. Mis võiks olla teistmoodi? Võibolla mis? Nagu. Tundub nagu veits ka enne. Nagu veider
Õpetaja: Siin Selles kõik linnad on natukene veider.
Õpetaja: No see on? Noh, ta alguses võib ees olla. Ta võib label ees ka olla, on ju
Õpetaja: Ee, aga point on see, et kõik linnad justkui Jäetakse mulje lisaasukoht, et, noh, kõikides linnades paned mingi selver. Näiteks kõik linnad Selver.
Õpetaja: Aga meil ei. Ole. Me Pigem tahaksin labelina öelda, midagi. Mis me tahaks öelda,
Õpetaja: kui see oleks label ees? Vaata, et mis suunab sind. Mida sa pead siin tegema?
Õpetaja: Vali linn.
Õpetaja: No aga milles probleemi.
Õpetaja: Proovime siis asju veits ümber.
Õpetaja: Mõtleme nüüd natukene loogiliselt, et kui meil ee, ühes dropdown is me tahame, et on kõik linnad, näiteks
Õpetaja: Ja teisel teine kord, kui me tahame seda kasutada, et ta on valilind, siis? Mis? Valilinn? Siis Mis meil on? Vaja Mis meil on vaja selle komponendiga juurde teha, või mis? Mis? Kuidas see lähenemine võiks olla, Et kuidas me saavutame selle, et vastavalt vajadusele see esimene valik
Õpetaja: on erinev,
Õpetaja: mis on vaja teha juurde kuidas? No see oleks lollus. Sellepärast siis sa seod selle komponendi mingisuguse kindla vaatega, Aga tema peaks Mitte midagi oma välisest elust teadma.
Õpetaja: Ifi ei tahaks
Õpetaja: mul veel.
Õpetaja: Me peame. See lahendus peab tulema.
Õpetaja: See lahendus peab tulema. Siin
Õpetaja: peab tulema See lahendus selles klotsis, et siia peab selle selle võimaluse võimekuse kuidagi looma.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate, kuidas võiks seda teha?
Õpetaja: Kuidas võiks seda, teha et praegult on siin see. Kas nõustute Praegult on see kõik linnad siia niimoodi hardcoditud,
Õpetaja: onju?
Õpetaja: Aga missioon on see, et see ei ole Hardcoditud vaid vastavalt vajadusele.
Õpetaja: Mis ma võiks teha sildikene, aga täpsemalt. Mis sildike?
Õpetaja: Ikka Natukene täpsemalt. Nagu mida meil on vaja. Mis meid aitaks. Siin.
Õpetaja: Vabandust, parameeter on juba üsna nagu hea asi. Aga mis see parameeter siin kontekstis on?
Õpetaja: Võta, on õige parameeter. Mingi sisend.
Õpetaja: No nüüd Ma võtsin ka kõik ära. Rohkem ei saa midagi öelda.
Õpetaja: Mida on vaja siin muuta. Mida on vaja teha?
Õpetaja: Sildikene on õige, õige märksõna. Parameeter on veel täpsem, aga pole ikka veel päris seesõna, mida mina.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me saaksime, et ei ole hardcoditud seal mingi tekste, vaid mingisugune Väärtus vastavalt vajadusele ei ole.
Õpetaja: No come on.
Õpetaja: Ei siuke.
Õpetaja: Ah,
Õpetaja: objekt. No, objekt võib olla. Jah, objekt ongi tegelikult string, et et ühel juhul võiks olla see kõik linnad. Teisel juhul võiks olla see, ee, Teisel juhul võiks olla see vali linn ja kolmandal juhul võiks olla See, mida iganes,
Õpetaja: et see on selles mõttes dünaamiline,
Õpetaja: muutu on õige.
Õpetaja: Aga. Aga palun aidake siin siin, selles selle komponendi kontekstis. Kui te ütlete muutuja, siis see, nagu see muutu, on õige. See sisu peab seal muutuma.
Õpetaja: Aga just selle komponendi kontekstis. Kui me räägime muutuja, siis
Õpetaja: Millest me siin nüüd peaks rääkima?
Õpetaja: Kas see komponent on täiesti eraldiseisev? Niiöelda üksus.
Õpetaja: Kas on niimoodi, et et siia siia valikutesse saab tegelikult panna, saab kaasa anda. Mida iganes.
Õpetaja: Me saame isegi öelda. Nagu. Et millist Millist Option It mõttes peab valima, et saab põhimõtteliselt seda teha,
Õpetaja: Siis Millest ma siin räägin?
Õpetaja: See on eraldiseisev komponent. Teda on võimalik Kuvada. Teda on võimalik kontrollida nii vastavalt vajadusele, mille abil
Õpetaja: okei, meetod Ja Ei, meetodi abil Ei, ei tee seda, mida on vaja. Siia nüüd atribuuti
Õpetaja: ehk Inglise keeles. Siin
Õpetaja: See ei ole atribuut ka, Okei, See on nagu järjest lähemal, Aga ikka, seda sõna ei ole tulnud. Nagu Mida siin on, vaja? Mis aitab meid siin kui dünaamiliselt meil See sisu tuleb kuskilt väljastpoolt. Me tahame
Õpetaja: täpselt samamoodi, et see sisu tuleks Kuskilt väljaspoolt Mitte ei ole sisse kirjutatud. Mida meil on vaja siia juurde.
Õpetaja: Mul on
Õpetaja: kuidas, Ee, ah? Täiesti lootusetu. Täiesti lootusetu.
Õpetaja: Ta nagu nii lähedal. Aga ta lihtsalt ei ütle nagu seda ühte sõna ära, et väljaspoolt tuleb mingi info, mis tuleb siia. Komponenti
Õpetaja: muutuja, atribuut, parameetrid, Kõike sõnu ütlete? Aga ainult ühte sõna ei ütle lihtsalt
Õpetaja: mis on siin samas lihtsalt silme ees,
Õpetaja: mida on vaja siia juurde, et väljastpoolt tuleb mingi info siia komponenti ja see oleks dünaamiliselt muutuks vastavalt vajadusele See esimene.
Õpetaja: Noh, ah, jah,
Õpetaja: noh, täpselt ei ole. See ei ole, see ei ole. Vaata, Muutuja On geneeriv asi. Parameeter on meetod,
Õpetaja: Atribuut on tegelikult täägi sees vaatame. Täägi. Sees on atribuut Siin on. Selle asja nimi props
Õpetaja: muutuja kui üldse. Võibolla võiks rääkida seal tatablokis. On Muutuja,
Õpetaja: see on. See on. See on selles mõttes väga eriline asi. See on selle komponendi Props. See on tema omadus, mida saab väljapoolt kaasa anda. Aga see sõna, mida ma kohe kaotasin, et üks Props tuleb juurde lisada.
Õpetaja: See on see, kus jõgi voolab sisse. See on See kastike konteiner, Sildikene
Õpetaja: Propsi. Ma ei tea, kas te võite. Te võisite isegi seda mõelda, et siia. Juurde. Noh, keegi peab isegi mõelnud,
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et su komponent ei tea oma välisest elust tööd ega mütsi
Õpetaja: ei tea ja ta ei peagi teadma, ta on Ainult Ta on alati ainult sõltuvuses. Selles mõttes, et keegi teda tarbib seal, kus keegi teda välja kutsub, Seal on nagu sõltuvus olemas, nagu, Et Okei, mina kasutan seda Child I.
Õpetaja: Aga kui vaadata seda komponendi enda vaatevinklist,
Õpetaja: Siin ei ole mitte ühte ainsa viidet ühegi teise failiga, Kõik,
Õpetaja: mida sa soovid. See on täpselt nagu samamoodi nagu meetrit parameeter. Sa soovid mingit tegevust teha. Kui sul on selle vajaks jaoks vaja mingeid andmeid. Siis sa pead parameetritega panema. Info kaasa.
Õpetaja: Siin on meil Propert Id. Kõik need valikud tulevad pealt.
Õpetaja: Kutsu mind välja, anna mulle See info. Mina joonistan sulle sinna. On nii,
Õpetaja: et soovid, et üks nendest valikutest oleks niiöelda valitud? Näete seal, kus on see rida neli At Valuve Selected City Id.
Õpetaja: Kui ühe oksjoni juures on välju, mis kattub selles väärtusega, siis see on aktiivne. Seda kuvatakse, aga. Gen,
Õpetaja: Kutsu, Kasuta mind. Anna mulle info kaasa.
Õpetaja: Aga siin ei ole mitte ühtegi viidet. Ei ole ega Locations Location Viole. Nad ei ole kuidagi seotud,
Õpetaja: Kui me tahame nüüd, seda, et siin, oleks miski, see esimene valik
Õpetaja: oleks. No, siin on üks variant. Veel muidugi, aga see oleks rõve. Juba ma nii ei teeks.
Õpetaja: Üks variant oleks veel selline. Ee, variant et me siis, enne kui me selle City Strop Down I me Pärime City Strop Down I
Õpetaja: Aa kuskilt Ee Back endist. Ja me paneme sinna ühe niiöelda elemendi juurde, Tekitame ühe nagu juurde, et City City Id on null ja name on näiteks. Aa, mis siin algselt oli? Aa,
Õpetaja: kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: Noh, siis ta joonistaks ja me kaotaks, nagu selle üldse Ära vaata. Selle Rea kaotaks üldse ära nagu kops.
Õpetaja: Aga parem variant on ju see, mis on rohkem loetavam, on see, et Siin on meil mingisugune First Option, onju? Nii
Õpetaja: siis me lihtsalt tekitakski lihtsalt siia juurde sellise võimekuse,
Õpetaja: et ütleme, et mis linn on,
Õpetaja: me Ütleme, millist asja valida. Ja nüüd me ütleme, et First Option Label ütleme, et see on string.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on võimalik seda komponenti välja kutsuda Niimoodi, et alla voolavad kõik opsjonid
Õpetaja: selline. Ee, niiöelda City It niiöelda It, mis tuleb niiöelda valida.
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd on meil Niukene muuta, et Pane mingi string kaasa. Ja see võiks nüüd olla siis see koht, kus me ütleme, et
Õpetaja: see tuleb sellest labelist.
Õpetaja: Do, said make sense, Nii, nüüd on meie valikud.
Õpetaja: Ma kirjutasin juurde ühe väärtuse, mida päriselt kasutatakse Ka
Õpetaja: Kuskil läheb kohe midagi automaatselt katki, mis? Kus läheb midagi katki. Mis te arvate,
Õpetaja: kui siin on? Nagu ennem, oli kaks muutujat Ja nüüd on üks juures, kus läheb midagi katki.
Õpetaja: Tublid ee, tublikaadi tegija, kus me kopisime.
Õpetaja: No, me otseselt ei ole kuskilt seda koppinud. Me Taaskasutame. Aga lihtsalt varasemalt. Me programmeerisime ära. Atm is View oli Nii
Õpetaja: kui me läheme praegult pangaautomaatid vaatele, siis on, nagu. Et ta ei Tal ei ole mingit sisu
Õpetaja: selleks esimeseks valikuks sellepärast, et Atms View. See koht, kus ta kasutab seda komponenti, annab kaasa ainult City S ja Cercet City Id on nii
Õpetaja: Nüüd veel, võimalus et me Teeme siia ühe rea juurde. Ma kohe. Ärge tehke vaid ise. Otsustame, kuidas teeme. Meil on kaks võimalust. Kas me tuleme siia kohta ja Parandame selle ära. Ütleme, et First Option Label
Õpetaja: saad sina väärtuse. Noh, et siin ei ole isegi vaja, et tuleb muutujast
Õpetaja: siin on nüüd Nagu nagu näitamegi, et vahel tahadki siit ringi panna. Mis asi see oli? Ee, kõik linnad, vä.
Õpetaja: Noh, nüüd see voolab siia alla, on Nii,
Õpetaja: tema Id on endiselt siin. Kenasti null, nii nagu me soovimegi.
Õpetaja: Ja kui ee, valik on kõik linnad siis on see valitud, on Nii,
Õpetaja: see on üks variant. Me muudame olemasolevat komponenti, Mis kuskil on kasutusel. Et kui me tekitame ühe Propsi juurde, me seda siin kasutame, Siis me läheme. Otsime üles, kust need on? Varasemalt Kasutatud ja parandame sealt ka ära. Aga alternatiiv? Taastan selle. Ei anna seda nagu kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: Aga teen niimoodi, et kui on kuskil ee seda varem kutsutud. Välja Mina lisan mingisuguse asja juurde. Ma ei tea, kus igal pool on seda kasutatud. Ma võibolla ei tahagi.
Õpetaja: Ma mõtlen, et Davai. Ma teen sellise asja, et vaikimisi. Alati. See on, ee, kõik linnad, aga Juhul,
Õpetaja: kui keegi tõesti päriselt annab ka. Siia. Vaata, näed, ma panen selle kõrvale. Näed, ma küsin, kas sind antakse kaasa
Õpetaja: Väärtus ei anta, Siis ma saan siin laiendada seda asja, et me ei ütle veel, et on string
Õpetaja: vaid Me ütleme, et. Oot, oot, oot, meil on siin veel mõned parameetrid, mida me tahame selle Propsi kohta öelda.
Õpetaja: Me tahame öelda tõesti, et ta on string,
Õpetaja: aga me tahame öelda, et Tema default väärtus, on
Õpetaja: nii? Kas siin antakse kaasa First Ee, Label First Option on label. Ei, ole, aga on ometi kõik linnad,
Õpetaja: te Saate aru, me me muudame mingit komponenti, mis on juba praegult süsteemis olemas.
Õpetaja: Siis kui me lisame juurde mingi Propsi. Ja kas me peame mõtlema. Aga kui kuskil keegi teda tarbib, siis selles kohas ei ole ju antud kaasa propsina väärtust,
Õpetaja: mis peaks siia sisse jooksma, siis me Saame selle ära lahendada. Näiteks niimoodi, et
Õpetaja: Davai, Et las ta olla siis niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on meil võimalus see üle sõita, Näiteks see Sama koht, kus on Atmsv, mis on juba ära tehtud.
Õpetaja: Kui ma ikka panen siia, ee ja panen. Aa,
Õpetaja: siis see esimene variant on see.
Õpetaja: Kui ma ei tee üldse seda, siis läheb nii, nagu on default.
Õpetaja: Saate mõttest aru. See on selline lähenemine, mida te saate ka mõelda, et kas ma muudan midagi? Kas seda on kasutatud
Õpetaja: Nii, kui me nüüd läheme selle Location View juurde tagasi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd. City Strop on on Annab siin kaasa. Citys ja Selected City Id. Kõik töötab,
Õpetaja: Kui ma lähen nüüd sinna asukohta,
Õpetaja: miks ta ei lähe? Aa, me ei muutu. Linki kunagi. Aa, poest. Ma ainult, ee. Tegin asukoht juurde. Aga kuhu ta viib,
Õpetaja: Kaldkriips? Meil on, vaja, et ta viib kaldkriips Location Väike pugi koos nästa
Õpetaja: seitseteist kohta on ka seal. Ee,
Õpetaja: pole veel midagi jõudnud teha siin Rohkemat nii
Õpetaja: kui nüüd minna. Asukoht, panga asukoht, Siis läheme lisaasukoht. Vaikimisi on kõik linnad.
Õpetaja: Kõik on õige sellepärast, et lööme nüüd uuele. Reale. Vaata, siin on ka parem näha. Vaata, hetkel on, Siin ee. Sealt aeg. Niimoodi lõppu. Hetkel läheb alla kaks asja. Cities Selected City Id, on nii?
Õpetaja: Mida me nüüd soovime teha? On see öelda, et. Oot oot, meil ei ole isegi seda muutujast vaja tingimata panna. Vaata, me teame, et siin kontekstis kui me kasutame Drop town. I Siis. Me Tahaksime et, first Option Label oleks
Õpetaja: vali linn ja. Nüüd siin kontekstis
Õpetaja: on meil selline tekst ees kas. Te Saate aru, mida me saavutasime praegu või? No mis me tegime
Õpetaja: nüüd? See on jälle nagu valikute küsimus. Me Me teame, et iga kord, kui Sa valid Tallinna, Siis ta saadab Id. Kui sa valid vali linna, siis ta saadab alati nulli.
Õpetaja: Palju ei ole muutunud. Näed, see on Drop Town Is fixed
Õpetaja: esimene. Valik first Label On alati null
Õpetaja: kui. Saadad aa Meetib, alati event I Ja ütleb et, näed võta, mis, Iganes on seal Väljumis, on hetkel see elektritud See läheb ka edasi nii nagu alati.
Õpetaja: Aga siin on üks väikene asi on see, et Kas me tahaksime teha ka niimoodi potentsiaalselt,
Õpetaja: et seda esimest asja? Ta on selles mõttes disabled,
Õpetaja: et niipea, et see on nagu hall, onju, et okei, sa maandud siia lehele sa valitud.
Õpetaja: Ee, siis peab ka ta olema. Selected Selected on Siin juba kirjas niikuinii
Õpetaja: kui sa elektri paned, on kuskile mujale, siis on midagi muud. See elekter.
Õpetaja: Ma panen näiteks Selected siia. Dünaamiliselt kõik Selected. Siis Ta võtab vist võibolla, esimese Kui ma selle võtan siit maha.
Õpetaja: Korra teen Refresh. Ma isegi ei tea, kuidas ta käitub. Tal on segadus. See ei tohikski nii olla. Selectat saab ainult ühel olla. Aga minu mõte on see, et kui siin oleks Niukene asi nagu disabled,
Õpetaja: siis ta käituks. Niimoodi valid Tallinna Vallilinna saad valida enam Moonshot Deal on ju,
Õpetaja: et kui sa. Kui sa vormile tuled ja seda kunagi ära ei märgi, ma kontrollima pead, niikuinii
Õpetaja: kontrollima pead. Absoluutselt igal juhul et Kas on
Õpetaja: aa niiöelda kas Aa, kas ta on siit midagi valitud või mitte? No kuidas ma Tean, Noh, Selected City Id ütleb ära. Ja kui Selected City Id on null, siis ma tean, et ta ei ole tegelt midagi veel valinud. Kui Selected City Id taustal, muutub tallinnaks või millekski muuks, on ju Noh, number kaks ja kolm siis ma tean, et ta on midagi valinud.
Õpetaja: Nüüd on see, et vaata, et et kuidas siis seda teha.
Õpetaja: Ma nüüd peast ei tea. Ma proovin korra. Ee, pole õrna aimu.
Õpetaja: Teeme veel ühe Propsi juurde. Sellepärast, et mu küsimus on see. Vaata, et me ei saa teda panna, ju Kui me oleme pangaautomaadis, on kõik linnad? Panid tallinna ära. Ahah, tallinnas on nii? Tartus on nii
Õpetaja: Pärnus On üldse jama, Vaata onju? Aga kõike linnasi enam ei saagi vaadata. Aga mis siis, kui ma tahan? Kas ma pean nüüd ise kõike klõpsima läbi ja nagu panema pildi kokku,
Õpetaja: et siin on Jälle see, et kui me tahame seda teha dünaamiliseks,
Õpetaja: et ühes kohas kasutame ühtepidi teisest teistpidi, siis mis meil on vaja, Ah,
Õpetaja: ei ole meil tsükkel lihtsalt massiivi pealt,
Õpetaja: mida meil on vaja. Ma ütlen, see City stop all Tabs. Ada, Tabs. See asi ei tea oma välisest asjast Mitte midagi,
Õpetaja: mis mõjutavad meil seda visuaali. Ma küsin uuesti, mis mõjutavad selles tehnoloogias meil visuaali, mida me näeme. Mida me
Õpetaja: saame puutuda Ja nii edasi.
Õpetaja: Okei, see on nüüd hästi. Straight. Vastus ja template osa. Aga selles mõttes, et mida seal template osas kokku pannakse, mille Pealt. Need, mille pealt see kokku tuleb
Õpetaja: andmete. Pealt. Nüüd ongi küsimus, et kui me tahame mõjutada seda asja, vaata, et vastavad valikuliselt, see Kas on disabled või mitte, onju? Siis see tähendab seda, et me peame
Õpetaja: tegema jälle mingisuguse propsi, Sest et see on ainukene võimalus, et Kõik, kes meid kasutavad, saavad suhelda läbi andmete
Õpetaja: andmed on see, mis drive Ib. Seda, mida kuidas näidatakse, mida tehakse,
Õpetaja: sest siis me ei Pea ise midagi programmeerima. Rohkem
Õpetaja: see süsteem ja arhitektuur ja lahendus hoolitsevad ise selle eest, et kõike näidatakse, mida vaja.
Õpetaja: Katsetuse värk pole õrna Aimu Proovime kui mina panen siia propsi.
Õpetaja: Ee, noh, iis ee. Mis asi oli, kui ma panin First Option,
Õpetaja: See on see peab olema Statement First Option is
Õpetaja: Disabled.
Õpetaja: Nii, mis tüüpi võiks see asi olla?
Õpetaja: Ku Kujutage ette selle statement. Iga on alati. Sa loe, lugege lihtsalt seda Ifi sees. Ja mõelge, kas see nagu klapib või mitte. If first option is disable then.
Õpetaja: Kui see nagu kõnetab, siis ta, see nagu See nimi on juba Fine.
Õpetaja: Et kui sa nagu näeksid, vaata seda sellises kontekstis. Option is disable Than. Okei, tundub, et on fine Tüüp on tal aga siin samamoodi. Nüüd on. Küsimus on see, et kas ma nüüd igalt poolt hakkan teda sisse andma või ma annan talle väike väärtuse.
Õpetaja: Ma pigem teeks niimoodi samamoodi, et ütlen, et Taip on
Õpetaja: Taip on poolen True They False ja Mm ja default väärtus on tal Force.
Õpetaja: Ma ei taha, et on. Ma tahan, et ainult siis, kui ma ütlen.
Õpetaja: Ee, siin. Jälle. Vot ma nüüd siin ma süntaks. Võibolla ma vajan chat i abi. Mina ei ole kindel, et saab anda atribuudiga.
Õpetaja: Ma ei ole kindel, aga ma proovin korra lihtsalt Ära vaata, et ee, vaikimisi. Ja ma praegult korraks panen. Selle lihtsalt truuks.
Õpetaja: Ma kohe näeks. Ära vaata, et kas on või ei ole, Tundub, et niimoodi töötab, on nii?
Õpetaja: Kõik linnad on ju kinni. Pangaautomaadid. Asukoht. Vahet pole, ei saa valida. Rohkem on nii? On Hall et
Õpetaja: Disabled Atribuut saab oma True We Falsey sellest muutujast. Nüüd Ma proovin korra ühte asja veel. Ma ei ole, kindel, kas see on toetatud siin või mitte.
Õpetaja: Ma ei ole kindel.
Õpetaja: Ee, Mis siis juhtub, kui ma panen selle nimeks ise? Ma korra vaatan Lihtsalt huvi pärast.
Õpetaja: Kas Tal on Niukene lühi.
Õpetaja: Kas tal on juhuslikult Niukene lühikene süntaks ka. Mis töötaks taustal.
Õpetaja: Vali linn on.
Õpetaja: Vaatame korra pangaautomaadid ka ära.
Õpetaja: Kui Ma panen selle False.
Õpetaja: Kuidas ta põhimõtteliselt seda teeb? On niimoodi. Kui muutuja nimi
Õpetaja: Aa klapib. Need on need reaktiivsed muutuja. Nimed on ju Kui Muutuja nimi klapib, siis ma ei pea kirjutama seda nagu topelt välja
Õpetaja: niimoodi saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Aga alati on lihtsalt küsimus. Vaata, et Kuidas see asi sind kõnetab? Hoopis kus sa seda komponenti välja kutsud?
Õpetaja: Sest et mida, kurat tähendaks see disabled, Kui ma vaataksin seda näiteks Aa,
Õpetaja: disabled võrdub true.
Õpetaja: Mis asi on? Kas terve tropta on?
Õpetaja: Noh, see ei kõneta, mind onju, et ma selles mõttes, ee, pigem nagu Näen, et ee, kui mul on siin First Option label on Ee, vali linn.
Õpetaja: Ja kui mul nüüd on siin juures hoopis nii, nagu Mul ennem olin. Ma teen tagasi. Control Z, Control, Z, Control Z, Control, Z, Kontrol, Z Control Z. Vot Nii
Õpetaja: kui on first Option, on Selle Selle Propsi nimi on First Optionist. Disabled,
Õpetaja: mis on puuleään? Vot nüüd on palju parem.
Õpetaja: Ehk atribuut, mis seda määrab, kas on Disabled või mitte, on. See on enda atribuut. Ta vajab veel truud või? Falsi Põhimõtteliselt,
Õpetaja: kui ma nüüd siin kasun, seda vaat kasutan, et First Option Label on. Vali linn.
Õpetaja: Tulen uuele reale ja ütlen.
Õpetaja: First Option is Disabled võrdub.
Õpetaja: Kui ma pärast panen truu, mis see on, Ta võtab seda kui stringi.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma. Kui ma panen Coloni ette, siis ta tegelikult võtab. Kui teda otse väärtust Ta mõtleb seda muutujast.
Õpetaja: Vot nüüd ma saan teha niimoodi, et mul on kahtepidi kahepidine. Niiöelda asi, et see on vaikimisi alati False
Õpetaja: vaikimisi. Kas ma tegin mingit Ma küsin, kas on ühtegi muudatust. Atm S viues
Õpetaja: ei ole, Aga ometi on see komponent. Seal kasutatud on ju aga kõik toimib. Vaatame Pangaautomaadid, kõik linnad. Olin tallinn,
Õpetaja: Olin kõik linnad, tulen. Asukoht ütleb hoopis mulle. Mitte kõik linnad, vaid vali linn ja on Disable D.
Õpetaja: Saate mõttest aru.
Õpetaja: Pretty Gustafa.
Õpetaja: Et see on klots, mida me saame kasutada,
Õpetaja: ja et ei tekiks mingisugust segadust siis
Õpetaja: siin. Ma tahan, et ta Käitub ühtepidi.
Õpetaja: Okei?
Õpetaja: Nagu miti ka soovib keegi?
Õpetaja: Noh, ütleme niimoodi. Et päriselus. Ee,
Õpetaja: paneks selle taaski. Vaata tee Niukene asi. No see see Ongi. Nagu see. See Igal pool on mõttekoht. Aga Seda see ei ole alati niimoodi, et absoluutselt kõik asjad peab super universaalseks tegema, ka Aa, et tuleb mõelda, mis? Mis see Kuidas on niimoodi. Siin on Niuke rusikareegel,
Õpetaja: Mida universaalsemaks soovid teha? Kas mingisuguseid komponente või siis näiteks Jaavas mingisuguseid meetodeid, et igal pool saab käigu kasutada. Vaata mingi asjaga. Ee, siis, ee. Ühel või teisel viisil tõuseb keerukus
Õpetaja: et ennem ei olnud ju seal neid sätteid Ennem ei olnud seal niimoodi. Ee, neid kahte propi juures ennem ei olnud mingeid lisa tingimusi. Ennem oli esimene Valik oli lihtsalt, ee. Kõik linnad ja thats it. Vaata, lihtne loetav.
Õpetaja: Tahan teha universaalsemaks. Okei, keuks tuleb juurde
Õpetaja: ja siis ongi see, et Tuleb leida nagu niukene tervislik tasakaal. Siis nende kahe vahel. Et nagu keerukusega mitte. Minna.
Õpetaja: Ja samal ajal, ee, et ikkagi on ikkagi see Asi ka et me ei kirjuta nagu samamoodi, nagu väga, palju uuesti ja uuesti. Lihtsalt natuke väikse variatsiooniga.
Õpetaja: Tabelid on minu meelest Niukene hea Näide
Õpetaja: admin näeb ühte veergu rohkem kui mitte admin. Näiteks
Õpetaja: siis on küsimus alati see. Vaata, kas mul oleks lihtsam teha kaks tabelit üks Mis on customer? Il ja teine Mis on komponent, mis on adminile?
Õpetaja: Kood on siis palju selgem vähem V, If, E ja asju aga Siis on nagu see. Vaata, et. Aga samas. Mul on siis väga palju koode, mis on tegelikult like for like sama,
Õpetaja: et sa pead Nagu lihtsalt natuke nagu hindama. Vaata, et kuidas. Nagu on. Ma arvan, päris Productionis. Ee, lihtsalt on ka. Nagu kuidagi. Aja jooksul hakkab tekkima mingisugune käekiri
Õpetaja: ja võib juhtuda seda. Vaata, et sa teed mingisuguse asja ja sulle öeldakse, et oota, et. Okei, ärme siin ärme siin tee Nagu seda universaalseks, et las ta olla eraldi. Lepime sellega, et meil on veel üks, mingi, üks, kaks faili veel ja mingit koodi kuskil kordub. Või siis vastupidi, Just et. Kuule,
Õpetaja: tegelikult sa kordad seda koodi, et. Noh, keegi leiab, et mina arvan, et oleks parem,
Õpetaja: aga ma ütlen. See on hästi. Niukene. Aa, päris Production Is. See on natuke Niukene õrn piir.
Õpetaja: Aa, sest et mina mäletan näiteks Aa, nii palju, Kui ma jaavat sain näppida Aa Eesti Energias Meil oli seal üks arendaja, kes tuli meeskonda. Ma ei tea, mis hetkel, aga see oli Kuskil keskel selle projekti mõttes, mis me olime hetkel teinud.
Õpetaja: Ja kuhu Ma nägin seda projekti Ja siis inimene oli õppinud ära nagu lambda, Funktsioonid ja streamid ja funktsionaalse programmeerimise. Mingid mõtted.
Õpetaja: Ja järsku tuli projekti selle asemel, et kasutada Spring Boot I. Ja ma muidugi praegu mõtlen.
Õpetaja: Ee, vot see on see kui mingid. Ee,
Õpetaja: kui kui ise osaled kuskil projektides ja pole veel kogemust, et kaasa rääkida arhitektuuris
Õpetaja: täna ma Nagu mõtleks küll, nagu. Kui ma saaks oma tänaste teadmistega olla. Eesti Energias tagasi selles projektis, mida me tegime. Ma oleks nii räigelt igasugustele asjadele vastu ja nõuaks, et me läheme mingi normaalsuse teed.
Õpetaja: Keegi mõtles ise oma andmebaasil leieri välja, kuidas andmebaasist andmeid pärida ja siis Aa Vanil jalgratta leiutamine
Õpetaja: Jalgratas leiutati. Lihtsalt teeme jalgratta. Teeme mingi nii põneva universaalse asja, millega nii minna, nagu mingi andmebaasi vastu minna, Aga lõpuks oli niimoodi, et sul läks nagu rämedalt aega. Vaata, et ise aru saada, mis teine kokku on keelatud. Kuidas seda asja kasutada. Ja kogu Aeg hakkasid tekkima mingisugused jamad.
Õpetaja: Sellepärast, et ei olnud kõik perfektne. Üks üks inimene mõtles, et savi. Nüüd on funktsionaalne programmeerimine meie projektis ja Tõmm. Paneme kõik järgi.
Õpetaja: Nots, täielik nots.
Õpetaja: Ee, tal polnud isegi unit teste nagu Ma lihtsalt mõtlen, nagu ma ei taha sellest rääkida,
Õpetaja: Ee, Et selles mõttes, et jah, Et kogemusega ilmselt tuleb siis see. Vaata, et kuidas. Ja projektides te näete ka käekirja.
Õpetaja: Võibolla ka midagi koledat Näete, kas te muidu sellest saite nüüd aru, Mis mu põhiline mõte oli? See
Õpetaja: jällegi, Et nagu meetodidki
Õpetaja: on komponendid. Samasugused eriti niuksed, Child Komponendid, mis on niuksed? Ee, Visuaalsed asjad, mida saab taaskasutada ja vaadata
Õpetaja: nendega, on nii lihtne, et kogu informatsioon, mis neil on vaja, tuleb kaasa anda. Props on see moodus, kuidas andmed sisse voolavad ja andmed on see, mis kontrollivad, mida näidatakse. Mida mitte jah, õige vastus oli ka see, et templateist näitame. Templateis on ära. Defineeritud Visuaalne pool
Õpetaja: Lähme edasi. Ee, Tulite järgi. Loodetavasti.
Õpetaja: Ee, Lähme selle Location View alla ära Ja saime selle linna paika. Võibolla üks asi, mis siin timmida
Õpetaja: on, see et ta on liiga lai.
Õpetaja: Noh, kui ta on selle kolumni sees. Öelge teie mulle, kuidas me seda kitsamaks teeme?
Õpetaja: Ei mäleta Mba Margin.
Õpetaja: Meil on kolm ja kolm numbriline laius. See kogu laius, mis tal praegult on. On siin kaksteist põhimõtteliselt selles kolumnis.
Õpetaja: No see on nagu niukse veits, Katse, eks? Et see meetodil nagu. Oi, oi, oi,
Õpetaja: Ei, see vist on ikkagi kogu osa praegu, et ma täpselt ei saa. Aru Noh, midagi Taolist.
Õpetaja: Vali hind.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: Kogu asi on tegelikult vist vasakule poole joonduv. Mul on niuke tunne, aga eks me pärast tegelikult kohe ka rohdes. Võime öelda Justify Content Center nagu et kõik Nad on nagu üldpildis. Kogu ekraan on nagu Keskel.
Õpetaja: Ta ei ole vasakule ega paremale.
Õpetaja: Ee, selle saime korda.
Õpetaja: Taaskasutaja komponenti andmed Päri Back end Id loos. Vaatekomponent.
Õpetaja: Ee, loo uus komponent. Location name input.
Õpetaja: Mm, bla blaa, blaa, bla, blaa, loo. Uus komponent location details.
Õpetaja: No okei, Jätame ta inputiks, Aga ma ise paneks ta sõna form nagu vorm.
Õpetaja: Sest mis seal on seal Vormil on väljad. Väli väli väli. Väli, Saate aru, vorm saab täita,
Õpetaja: aga või Jah, ee, piltidel Lihtsalt on see juba olemas. Meil neid ei saa muuta.
Õpetaja: No okei, las siis olla sama uus komponent.
Õpetaja: Aga nüüd on jällegi see mõte, et Kas me. Tahame teha kohe seda komponenti?
Õpetaja: Võibolla teeks kogu selle asja valmis Kõigepealt visuaalselt. Kasvõi.
Õpetaja: Okei, kuhu me peame selle tegema? Koodis. Mis reale?
Õpetaja: Kus ta on?
Õpetaja: Kaheksateist siin. Jah,
Õpetaja: et siin on see järgmine mõistlik on jälle Vaata, teeme oma elu lihtsamaks, et tõmbame selle eelmise. Need eelmised koolid. Tõmbame kokku ja keskendume ainult sellele, mis meid huvitab hetkel
Õpetaja: See Vorm.
Õpetaja: Võibolla lüüa. Ma ütlen ka oma arenduse käigus. Löön alati lihtsalt natuke tühjust, et kus ma oma fookust hoian?
Õpetaja: No kui me Hakkame vaatama, mis siin tuleb, et nüüd seda ee. Rohelist kasti me hetkel ei vaatame. Hoopis keskendume nendele.
Õpetaja: No mis mõte siin on
Õpetaja: ja input. Aga mis mõte veel? Nagu, et lihtsalt kas kirjutanp ja hakkame lammutama või?
Õpetaja: Ah, Bootstrap,
Õpetaja: Mäletate loo kinil ju kasutasime mingisugust ee, enamvähem Mingit, ee, viisakat asja niukest asja tahaks kasutada uuesti. Mulle meeldib see küll Ütlem, et siin sees on see
Õpetaja: kind a place Holder või Niiöelda label, mäletate?
Õpetaja: Aa, minu meelestrapist. Selle leidsime lõpuks sõna ka. Label See sama email ongi. Põhimõtteliselt võtaks selle esimese Dv.
Õpetaja: Te ütlesite siiamaani Label.
Õpetaja: Te võite juba seda osa teha. Vaata, panna seda sinna plöraki maha.
Õpetaja: No kuule, ongi vist.
Õpetaja: Jaa, okei, ma olen nõus. No võtame Log in views selle tegelikult, Sest seal on mingid texttyped ja asjad, onju Login Views.
Õpetaja: Kus ta meil nüüd siis on? Ee, ai, aga Siin on natukene palju asju veemodel. Ja.
Õpetaja: Ei, no Davai. Võtame siis. Vahet pole, ka Võtame.
Õpetaja: Teeme selle kopi ära.
Õpetaja: Oot, oot, oot, oot, Võtsin valesti juba. Miks
Õpetaja: see tegelikult see osa on? Osa sellest lahendusest.
Õpetaja: See siin see ka. Jah, ja võtke koppi, aga ärge seda plöraki asja veel. Tehke.
Õpetaja: Ee, Kas vastad tõele, et kus mul nüüd see taas ka on?
Õpetaja: Kas vastab tõele, et lõpuks peab tekkima Niukene? Ee, Selline niiöelda komponent nagu Location details import.
Õpetaja: Tema lõpuks peab olema template sees. Ja templateis saab olla ainult üks Child.
Õpetaja: Siis minu mõte on, et teeme juba praegult need, mis nüüd kõiki neid välju, hakkab niiöelda sees hoidma. Ehk teeme Tab Enter Saate mõttest aru. See ongi see Roheline piir. Põhimõtteliselt,
Õpetaja: et see osa läheb pärast Templetisse. Ja siis seal on ainult üks Child.
Õpetaja: Kas siin on kellelgi küsimusi, et üks Child
Õpetaja: et kui me teeme uue komponendi
Õpetaja: Templeti vahel peaks olema ainult üks Child on nii,
Õpetaja: et siis see hakkab olemagi meie meie div,
Õpetaja: sest et Siis tuleb üks. Aa, üks. Niiöelda vorm tuleb.
Õpetaja: Teeme siis jooksvalt selle kohe korda. Võibolla siis Publitseerime seda ka, on ju Ee, meil ei hakka enam olema. Esimene asi hakkab olema asukoht.
Õpetaja: Siis, mis võiks olla? Mulle väga ei meeldi nii teha aga teeme siia juba põhimõtteliselt Databloki muutujad, mida me kavatseme kasutada,
Õpetaja: ei taha Username I vaid tahame.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma pakuks, et Location Name oleks siin korrektne.
Õpetaja: See on location Name input siis võibolla võiks mõelda niimoodi, et Location
Õpetaja: nii ühtlasi tasub mõelda. Mis? Ee, mis Asju, mis nimesid me juba oleme näinud oma sõnumites, Sest et. Tegelikult need võiksid olla need samad
Õpetaja: Väike Jah, on.
Õpetaja: No tegelikult ärme tee praegult seda. Osa. Mulle ei meeldi niimoodi, et on katkine kood.
Õpetaja: Paneme. Me teeme selle veemodeli siia. Hiljem
Õpetaja: teeme selle visuaali ära. Ärme tee niimoodi. Ma ütlen, et ma tean, ma juba Tegelt tean, kuidas see lõpus enam vähem läheb. Siis Ee, siis nii on. Aga see Id ja see label. Need vist olid kõik vajalikud, et nad töötaksid ja need peavad ka omavahel kattuma. Aa, need siis igaks juhuks teeme input.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: tegelikult oleks mõistlik siin mitte kirjutada üle vaid kuidas teha.
Õpetaja: Kuidas oleks, et ma pean siin seda muutma? Ja pärast pean siin seda muutma. Mis Me. Teeme,
Õpetaja: Refactor Rename, mis? Mis Vajut on Shift F kuus.
Õpetaja: Ja see siis oli location Name ja input. Vist oli mõte vä
Õpetaja: Input location. Kui meil oli ennem niimoodi, Siis me teeme tõesti sama sama järjekorraga. Hoiame käekirja Input Location Name.
Õpetaja: Aa, refaktor. Oo, ärge nüüd seda vajuta. Refaktorit vä
Õpetaja: Olge ettevaatlikud. See Nimi, mis siin ennem oli Input. Username on ka kasutatavad,
Õpetaja: et me soovime siin, et Skop ei ole Project Files vaid Kurven File,
Õpetaja: sest et Ta läheb ee. Hulluks.
Õpetaja: Ta leiab selle sama kuskilt praegu. St Seal on täpipead. Sama sõna. Aa, siis On input location. Need kaks Muutusid ära. Place solder. No, selle siin ei ole refaktoreerida. Kuna need ei ole omavahel selles mõttes Connected Ee
Õpetaja: asukoht,
Õpetaja: asukoht Copy Control V Ja võib siis minna juba piiluma.
Õpetaja: Kas on õige?
Õpetaja: No ma piilun ka ka ära. Siis
Õpetaja: on nii.
Õpetaja: Siin võib ka juba sellel koolil ka natukene kitsendada, et see sama kool, mille sees kõik need ee, vormiväljad hakkavad olema.
Õpetaja: Ma annan siia kolm, kolm, näiteks vaatame.
Õpetaja: Ei ole Suur Võtame kogu sellest ulatusest praegult ikkagi kolgaks.
Õpetaja: Noh,
Õpetaja: ma ei tea, Käib ka.
Õpetaja: Okei? Ee,
Õpetaja: jah, põhimõtteliselt üks on olemas võibolla, võib panna juba on siin olemas. No, minu mõte on nüüd, et äkki lööme siis tublikaadi selle eest. Ja järgmine on ju tegelikult väga sarnane, on Lihtsalt automaatide arv,
Õpetaja: et võtame selle Dv. I, Mitte selle välise Dv. See See saab olema meie komponendi Tv. Sellest teeme Dublikaadi
Õpetaja: jällegi. Seda Võib lihtsalt kokku võtta see hetk niimoodi, et Control D tubliqueid.
Õpetaja: Järgmine ei ole enam input location name. Ma ei viitsi re refaktureerida. Lihtsalt Kirjutame input Number of Fake games
Õpetaja: number off Atms.
Õpetaja: Ma lihtsalt kopin selle siia alla. Foori ka.
Õpetaja: Muidugi hüppas ühele reale, kuna nüüd on Natukene lühem tekst. Ja mis siin on automaatide Arv Place Holder, Aa,
Õpetaja: tomaatide arv.
Õpetaja: Ja see tuleb copile Pane siia.
Õpetaja: Ühe asja peab veel sinna ära muutma.
Õpetaja: Mis te arvate
Õpetaja: taipan number?
Õpetaja: Võibolla võiks ühe atribuudi veel juurde panna nagu min.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis numbrist alates võiks hakata automaatide Arv,
Õpetaja: Võibolla üks, Nagu et nagu. Mis mõtet on mingit asukohta panna? Kus automaatide arv on?
Õpetaja: Null vä Jätame selle niimoodi.
Õpetaja: Võib korra vahepeal piiluda Ka automaatide arv. Näete, nüüd on nagu see, et saad numbritega ülesse minna. Näiteks kui tahad. Noh, saad ka trükkida. Loomulikult, onju
Õpetaja: aga saad alla minna. Aga mis see viimane number
Õpetaja: Loomulikult see ei tähenda, et ei võiks siin mingit jama korraldada või,
Õpetaja: ee, et siin, on Mingid asjad, mida nagunii peab programmiliselt natukene Ee, jälgima.
Õpetaja: Miinus Kümme noh. Mis. Tähendab siis huvi peale tingimus
Õpetaja: koodi
Õpetaja: tähendab seda seda ei ole mõtet teha. Nagu, et. Et sa siin survestad inimest, et ta juba hakkab midagi vinguma Suga lõpuks. Inimene peab vajutama. Mitte su nuppu. Vaata, et Lisa,
Õpetaja: eks? Siis saab tõreneda inimesega ja öelda, et miinus kümme ei saa
Õpetaja: aga, saaks seda kindlasti ka teha ära et, siin jälgitakse Ja nii pea, kui paned mingit jama, hakkab kohe vinguma,
Õpetaja: tuleb mingi lahtrike või mis iganes.
Õpetaja: Ee, see on, Niuke Cloud I teema ka Oskaks kindlasti pakkuda mingit elegantset lahendust.
Õpetaja: Nagu Kuidas, seda teha.
Õpetaja: Okei, automaatide arv on meil paigas. Mis veel,
Õpetaja: Ahah checkbox.
Õpetaja: No mis mõtted, on Checkbox E. On vaja kolm tükki neid seal lausa. Selle pildi järgi.
Õpetaja: Vaatame selle asja nimeliselt. On checks.
Õpetaja: Ei ole nagu need tšekid. Vaata, Et nagu kui Eesti keeles, et andke mulle tšekki ka, et
Õpetaja: panen kuskile oü arvetesse Default Checkbox võiks justkui tö töötada Meile
Õpetaja: võtame selle Ülemise näite. Pange tähele siit siiani
Õpetaja: Selle vana divi lihtsalt korra kinni panna. Siit Ee, et ei oleks silme ees ja lihtsalt tuua, et Järgmine
Õpetaja: tuleb.
Õpetaja: Vaatame. Ka, mis siin on. It Default Checkbox. Tegelikult siin ei ole vaja.
Õpetaja: Siin on vaja ühte teist asja, kui Id sinu jaoks on vaja name.
Õpetaja: Ei ole Tegelikult seal pole Ready ja Button. Seal. Pole midagi, vaja.
Õpetaja: Aa. Ma Arvan, et kuni siiamaani saab ära kustutada.
Õpetaja: Input for input type checkout. Siis ma korra piilun. Kas sealt midagi Tundub, et on okei, onju
Õpetaja: Ee, Sisu tuleb siit labelist Aa Foor on ju ka, on ju?
Õpetaja: Aa, mul on ikka tunne, et sõidame üle Seekord mine saa ka oma fooriga
Õpetaja: või kui me paneme, Vaata, Teil on. Meil on vaja üks asi aru saada. Me Võime selle Id, panna, aga me peame siis hoidma meeles, seda saab võtta tagasi. Aa, Id. Aa, No mis Id võiks olla?
Õpetaja: Ee, mis need on? Ee, transaction
Õpetaja: Taip.
Õpetaja: Ja ma panen siia Id ja ma panen Hetkel numbri üks.
Õpetaja: Me peame aru saama, et Id D. Kui sellist väärtust võib Html is olla. Ühel lehel ainult ühe korra,
Õpetaja: Aga kas Vastab tõele, et ega me siin kolme tükki ei pane, Vaid Kuidas need pidid tulema?
Õpetaja: Ma saaniksin midagi ka. Jääp is ju. Vaata,
Õpetaja: näete seda Gt Atm Transaction types.
Õpetaja: Need tulevad vastavalt massiivile. Nii mitu objekti on
Õpetaja: ja sisuga, et kas vastab tõele, et me hakkame dünaamiliselt tegema seda staafi põhimõtteliselt
Õpetaja: see omakorda tähendab. Paneb selle Marge fotoni ka juba kohe ära.
Õpetaja: Aga ma ei ole, kindel, kas me siin tahame seda teha.
Õpetaja: Korra peaks dubleerima seda vaatama. Lihtsalt pulli pärast. Nagu et ma kordan enda arvutis seda, et.
Õpetaja: Aga kuidas nad nagu visuaalselt jääksid, ah, Täitsa okei. Ja on ju ee, et, ee.
Õpetaja: Kui dünaamiliselt hakkab tulema seda asja mitu korda, siis kõigil ei saa olla sissekirjutatud kujul vähemalt Niukene nimi.
Õpetaja: Küll
Õpetaja: saame me selle teha. Sellepärast, kui me vaatame andmeid, Me saame võtta neid väärtuseid, sõltumata aru, aga me peame meeles hoidma seda lihtsalt,
Õpetaja: et sellest tuleb ju mingi four ära, et. Hästi,
Õpetaja: noh, paneme mingi nime ka siis. Aa, lihtsalt. Aa. Me paneme siis sularaha sisse
Õpetaja: ja vaatame
Õpetaja: Saate mõttes aru, kas meil on mõtet dubleerida neid teisi siia? Või Te saate juba aru, et niikuinii on ainult lõpuks seda vaja,
Õpetaja: sest et selle järgi tsükliliselt, me teeme seda sama elementi nii palju kui on andmeid.
Õpetaja: Okei,
Õpetaja: nii paneme Ee, selle ka hetkel kinni.
Õpetaja: Oota, mis järgmiseks on?
Õpetaja: Imešimput. Ee, vali pilt.
Õpetaja: Taaskis Öeldakse ka, et see tuleb sellest failist.
Õpetaja: September, kaks tuhat, kakskümmend, seitse, kakskümmend viis.
Õpetaja: Ma Ei, tea, vaatame. Miuke, see on. Ma just mõtlen, kas saab olla uuemad? Ma pakun ettei Kusjuures
Õpetaja: Davai Download ma annan teile ka Kohe
Õpetaja: tundub, et ma olen juba seda siin varem kasutanud, et ma pigem otsin selle originaali üles,
Õpetaja: Vaatan, millal see sai tehtud.
Õpetaja: Noh, ta on Siin kõrval. Lahti kuskile. Nii Ee, Download.
Õpetaja: Ma vaatan korra lihtsalt huvi. Pärast printsiibis image input
Õpetaja: Tundub suht sama kuupäevaga. Ilmselt on see sama, aga siin on natukene uuem, On ju mingi hetk.
Õpetaja: Panen selle siia uuesti Pane korra. Dokument siia alla. Lihtsalt.
Õpetaja: Nii, ma annan teile Kohe selle faili
Õpetaja: Aa slaki. Viskan. Te võite oma slaid lahti teha. Juba
Õpetaja: Kus sa nüüd oled siin?
Õpetaja: No siin.
Õpetaja: Aa, mul ei ole Lahtist läks. No teeme sloki lahti. Äkki on kirjutanud mulle. Ma ei teagi.
Õpetaja: Projekteerime online kasiino Ohoo,
Õpetaja: paar esimest klienti. Lihtsalt ee Hoiad kuidagi Ja see pappi tuleb
Õpetaja: W. If Iga Kümnes käsi kaotab suurelt ja ongi olemas nii võtke. Tee selle ka
Õpetaja: aa. Nüüd. Kus, te mis, te tahate teha, on see, et download ite selle alla nii nagu ikka. Aitate seda download nuppu.
Õpetaja: Teete lahti selle faili.
Õpetaja: No teile ta ei jää numbriga, vaid niisama jääb.
Õpetaja: Ja siis, mis te teete, on see, et ee, panete endale akna ühele poole, teete Control C ja Kontrol, Copy on lihtsam.
Õpetaja: Sa nüüd on jälle siin, Näed aga nii?
Õpetaja: Otsite faili ülesse. Control C, Teete lahti ja komponents kasta peale Vajad Control.
Õpetaja: Noh, mis te vajutate?
Õpetaja: Control, E, oota. Mis see kell on? Ühe teemasi jõuab rääkida, Aga tähtsad teemad.
Õpetaja: Nii mhmh Okidoki. Ee, kohe Vaatame saite selle tehtud
Õpetaja: lähme nüüd tagasi sinna. Location View Sse. Niiöelda, Ja ma mõtlen korra, kuidas me teeme.
Õpetaja: Ma vist teeks kuidagi, niimoodi, et ma dubleeriks selle kõige viimase asja. Selle checkbox i uuesti.
Õpetaja: Ma pigem võtaks niimoodi siit selle keskmise Four floating.
Õpetaja: Ma tahan ainult tegeleda. Ärme tee niimoodi. Võtame lihtsalt. Mis siin on, Mb. Kolm. See ei ole palju Kirjutada Pigem, Paneme need tiivid kinni
Õpetaja: ja teeme lihtsalt ühe Divi siia juurde. Ise käsitsi.
Õpetaja: See copy basimine lihtsalt ajab rohkem segadusse.
Õpetaja: Ee Div, onju? Ja siia paneme Class.
Õpetaja: Paneme sama asja mingi siis Ta on nagu form.
Õpetaja: Kuigi ma ei tea, kas ee
Õpetaja: kindlalt ta töötab niimoodi. Mb. Kolm.
Õpetaja: Mida iganes nii
Õpetaja: tegelt ma vaatan, kui rääkisin, On üldse mingi template? Siis on juba midagi olemas. Aa, siin on juba Class. Mb. Kolm.
Õpetaja: Aa, Siis vist isegi pole vaja. Kustutage lihtsalt Ära seal juba sees on Niikuinii midagi olemas. Tiimi tiimime. Seda kui on midagi vaja. Nüüd me soovime seda image Input I kasutada, et on komponentide all olemas. On siin olemas.
Õpetaja: Kuidas me saame nüüd seda komponenti siin kasutada? Me oleme tegelikult seda juba teinud.
Õpetaja: Mis me kirjutame? Mis me teeme,
Õpetaja: Paneme suured, on ju? Ja juba ta näeb seda voe komponenti noolega alla jaoks. Tab
Õpetaja: ja üks kaldkriips et saab, aru, Et et see on nagu üksik tagiga
Õpetaja: korra vaadata juba, kuidas ta siis selle tuli? Nagu Juice File tuli.
Õpetaja: Ee, jah, Ee, ainukene asi Vaata sellele viimasele Form check ile tasuks ka panna. See margin bottom, et nad elavad kuidagi liiga üksteise kaelas hetkel mööda.
Õpetaja: Võibolla pärast peab seda vaatama natukene.
Õpetaja: Ee, mulle tundub, et siit ei üldse ei näe Nagu ööd ega mütsi.
Õpetaja: Ee, ma korra vaatan korra. Me ei leia, et kuidas taaskis justkui välja nägi?
Õpetaja: Ma tahaks selle vali valipilt. Võibolla jätta pigem
Õpetaja: pigem jätta välja sellest kolumnist ja reast
Õpetaja: ehk minu mõte on see, et teeks juurde. Ühe Vaatame, kas see vana Row üldse lõppeb.
Õpetaja: Et teeks niimoodi, et esialgu paneks selle roo kinni rida. Kaheksa,
Õpetaja: Ma. Ma arvan, et see visuaalis jääb kuidagi parem välja. Kui me jätame ta kolmandaks reaks Eraldi
Õpetaja: Ee, Kirjutame siia. Div, tab Enter ja Anname talle ka klassi Pro Ja Justify Content Center
Õpetaja: Ja nüüd lähme võtame selle sama Input I mis me just tegime A üks, kolm ka, onju? Ee,
Õpetaja: Glass Call ja kohe Timmime laiust ja kõiki asju. Vaata
Õpetaja: ja nüüd läheme. Võtame selle image input. I
Õpetaja: tõstame siia tagasi, See on hästi lihtne, onju? Control X, Onju
Õpetaja: või? Otsides uus koht kontroll V.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, et oleks vähem pläusti sees, siis me korra võime selle üldse kokku võtta ja keskenduda ainult sellele osale, Onju,
Õpetaja: et, Ee, see visuaal vist.
Õpetaja: Ee, läheb vähe paremaks.
Õpetaja: Teeme siis temale ka, et Sellele anname mingi mõistliku asja niimoodi et, see meile tundub siin enamvähem. Fine.
Õpetaja: Et, kolm ja sidekriips proovime. Siis esialgu kolm näiteks, vaatame. Kuidas, ta välja näeb, okei?
Õpetaja: Mingil põhjusel Kõik need asjad on endiselt veel nihkes, aga küll nad lähevad kokku koos sellega lõpuks. No saate aru, ma Tahtsin sellele jätta suuremat laiust,
Õpetaja: kui sellele asjale siin.
Õpetaja: Nüüd Juice File.
Õpetaja: Kui mina valin mingi imidzi. Hetkel midagi ei juhtu, aga taustal ta selle tegelikult valib.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, Ee, aega on vähe. Nüüd ma nüüd võib puhata. Ma teen Comiti ära. Vaata, et kas me jõuame midagi veel progeda, eks? See selgub,
Õpetaja: ee. Aga ma panen selle põhimõtteliselt kui mi buss tähele. Te ei pea kiirustama, et järgi jõudes, et nüüd on vaatamise koht korras.
Õpetaja: Nimi Džinpot. Kui me tuleme siia sisse.
Õpetaja: Ee, kuidas see asi suures pildis Töötab?
Õpetaja: Et Ee, tema ülesse Näete, mul on Siin input. Change. Mis Change teeb
Õpetaja: Esiteks vaatame input. Seda referentsi korra. Ee, ignoreerime korra. Varem Rääkisin teile sellest Ka siin on seda Lihtsalt vaja Input ja Fail Type on file jälle. See on Html i Tavaline input, aga mitte tekst, mitte email, mitte number, vaid file
Õpetaja: Siin Accept osas öeldakse ära, et ole, et sina võid nõustuda. Bng, Ga, jpg, ga ja gif. Iga.
Õpetaja: Me saame, et kui see aken Tuleb lahti meile. Ee, browser is, et vali mingi fail. Siis ta juba teeb selle. Narrow Down I. Ära vaata. Ta näitab ainult neid Faile, mida saab, valida, Ehk siis kõiki kaustu
Õpetaja: ja ainult faile. Kui Pdf ei saa valida Antud hetkel arusaadav, kui Aa limits, käivitub,
Õpetaja: siis Tema event i küljest. Mäletate Event
Õpetaja: Event Target. Meil oli välju. Aga selle input i puhul on temal niisugune target nagu files.
Õpetaja: Pakkuge, Mis See See kask null on Siin
Õpetaja: See on nagu massiiv. Tegelikult me saame niikuinii valida. Ainult ühte faili korraga, aga tema saab failid massiivina, et kui ma tahan valida mitut, siis ma saan mitut faili korraga valida ja siis saaks justkui valida, et tema võtab selle esimese faili välja.
Õpetaja: Ee, teeb lihtsalt siin. Sellest Failist Aa Selected image muutuja.
Õpetaja: Nüüd, See kuidas ta selle pildi juba kätte saab, on tegelikult sellises kodeeringus Nagu base. Kuuskümmend neli. On keegi kuulnud Sellest Midagi
Õpetaja: pole midagi olnud.
Õpetaja: Kas kunagi. Ei olnud mingi kasseti tootja või midagi taolist?
Õpetaja: Kuuskümmend neli. Ma Ei, tea, mida, kas mida tähendab või mitte. No mitte tähendab seda, et läheb. Event Event Selected
Õpetaja: nüüd Siin See base. Kuuekümne neljas on natukene hookuspookus, mis tegelikult teeb selle pildi
Õpetaja: Base Kuuekümne nelja fo Niiöelda kodeeringusse base. Kuuskümmend neli that viis, kuuskümmend neli.
Õpetaja: On siis ee, Võimalus Kuidas saab võtta põhimõtteliselt mingisugused koledad andmed. Kus on mingid koledad sümbolid, nagu loogilised Sulud. Aa Youtu märgid. Ja Mingid niuksed asjad asjad. Mis on sõnumites üsna ohtlikud, Kuna nad võivad sõnumi kandja ära rikkuda.
Õpetaja: Kui sul on Jason
Õpetaja: ja sa paned Jason Isse mingi sisu, kus on mingisugused jutumärgid ja komad ja asjad. Siis asjad lähevad sealt katki potentsiaalselt. Sellepärast, et meil on võti ja väärtus, mille sees on String
Õpetaja: String on väärtusena jutumärkide sees. Kui Nüüd, seal teksti keskel tuleb jutumärgid, siis tegelikult. Jason on katki
Õpetaja: Base Kuuskümmend neli lahendab seda muret, siin Ei ole mingi turvaasi.
Õpetaja: Siin on nagu selles mõttes, et mingi. Nagu et on mingi salasõna ja mingi väärtus ja midagi tavaliselt see pole See on see, et me võtame mingi ühe asja ja paneme teise vormi.
Õpetaja: Nii,
Õpetaja: mina võtan lahti. Kuna tegemist on piltidega, siis mina võtan lahti. Kaks erinevat lehekülge. Täiesti suvaliselt. Panen näiteks siia. Image
Õpetaja: too base. Kuuskümmend neli, kuuskümmend, neli. Guru Dot com. Ei ole väga lahe image To Base. Kuuskümmend neli.
Õpetaja: Sina vali mingi pilt, mina teen sellest teksti,
Õpetaja: Aga mitte mingid nullide. Ühed või midagi muud, mis iganes, vaid base. Kuuskümmend neli.
Õpetaja: Vaatame Väga ohtlik tegevus. Mul siin. Mis pildid mul siin võivad olla.
Õpetaja: Jumal Seda teab, kas ta saab narrotauni teha. Ma vaatan Mingit pilti
Õpetaja: confluences. Noh, vast Pole midagi erilist,
Õpetaja: kui meil on selle pildi valinud.
Õpetaja: Huvitav, me ei näe seda pilti. Mm,
Õpetaja: võiks nagu näha, Nagu vähemalt ju ka ju.
Õpetaja: Screenshot. Bn G, Võtame selle.
Õpetaja: Võta nagu ma lähen minema siit.
Õpetaja: Kuuskümmend neli Ee D võib olla. Ma tahaks pilti näha ka, et nagu see on nagu selle sisu.
Õpetaja: Näete seda pilti siin, Ah, nii väike aeg.
Õpetaja: Mm, on veel midagi moodi.
Õpetaja: Ma korra Tahtsin Oota korra. Ma panen siit. Ee, niimoodi. Tõesti viu viu, viu, viu, view, viu, viu, large, extra large.
Õpetaja: Noh, see on ka Mingi väike pilt.
Õpetaja: Oi, oi, oi, oi, Slack.
Õpetaja: Tulevad juba siin. Mingisugused kohad Asjad,
Õpetaja: Kurat küll, Nagu mingi normaalset kohta. Kuuskümmend neli Image Preview Äkki siin näeb nagu ühe suuremalt ka. Äkki mul on muidugi väga väikselt. Vot see võis ka viga olla muidugi.
Õpetaja: Parem Hästi,
Õpetaja: Mm,
Õpetaja: Svg. Noh, on Slack.
Õpetaja: Ta muidugi toetab, saate aru? See sama pilt on tegelikult tehtud teksti kujul valmis.
Õpetaja: Kui meil oleks see kuskil Html is
Õpetaja: Näete image Source data ja oleks selline tekst. Kogu see kamara jura siin.
Õpetaja: Ma võin võtta isegi selle,
Õpetaja: kui ma tulen praegu. Location View Sse ja panen näiteks siia. Image input I alla.
Õpetaja: On see sama pilt siin,
Õpetaja: et see base kuuskümmend neli juba vaikimisi sobib sinna atmise image komponenti. Tõestada veel seda ära, et praegult. Mina olen Code Beautify. Olen, mis iganes kohas on, ju
Õpetaja: ma võtan lihtsalt selle base kuuekümne Nelja nagu stringina.
Õpetaja: Ee, Teen tublid ja lähen kuhugi mujale. Kui Code Beautify.
Õpetaja: Nüüd ma võin võtta mingi. Tagasi. Ma võtan base. Kuuskümmend neli, To Image.
Õpetaja: No võib proovida nüüd seda bacecurut. Näiteks
Õpetaja: kaks erinevat kohta. Üks on siin. Neil. Ei ole mingit Connection It.
Õpetaja: Üks on siin, Kui mina panen siia stringi ja nüüd on üks on N. Code,
Õpetaja: siin on. Vaata end, Code.
Õpetaja: See on kuuskümmend neli image Preview Image
Õpetaja: on siin pilt all. Kas te saate aru, Tegemist on tekstiga. Ja kui seda teksti hoolikalt vaadata?
Õpetaja: Ta on suht lollikindel sellepärast, et siin Ei ole mingisuguseid jutumärke ja muid koledaid asju, mis meid? Mida me vihkame? Tühikuid pole.
Õpetaja: Jutumärke pole.
Õpetaja: Ta on tehtud selli, ta on valatud sellisesse vormi. See on mingi algoritm, mis teeb Iga kord on täpselt sama tulemus.
Õpetaja: Mida on võimalik siis teha Mõlemat pidi? Vaata, et võta, mingisugused. Võin see Jason I ka panna. Näiteks või mis iganes see võib olla, sa võid mis? Iganes teksti anda ja tema nüüd algoritmiga Vaatab seal igasuguseid sümboleid asju
Õpetaja: ja tema nende asemel asendab siis lihtsalt mingi tähtede ja numbrite kombinatsiooniga. Vaata mis põhimõtteliselt on teisendamine, ta teisendab
Õpetaja: kodulehel ja vaata, Point on see, et mina küsin. Vaata, nagu seda, et et kuidas. Kurat ta siis pild. Ma lisan pildi Facebook. Ma Lisan oma pildi.
Õpetaja: Küsimus on see. Vaata, et. Aa. Kuidas seda pilti hoitakse andmebaasis sellepärast, asi, mida nad ei taha teha, on see, et Sul rakendis ja serveris on mõttes aru. Pildid on ju päeva lõpus andmed. Kui ta on faili sees
Õpetaja: pilt, seda ka on tegelikult andmed on ju Meil on vaja hoida andmeid, kus me hoiame andmeid andmebaasis
Õpetaja: ja seal on vaja hoida asju ja vajadusel taas esitada. Ja nüüd On lihtsalt küsimus, kuidas me seda saame teha. Igasuguseid lahendusi, on, et igasuguseid lahendusi on olemas,
Õpetaja: aga enamus veebilehed arvatavasti teevad mingi niukse protsessi ära, et esiteks on seal mingi fototöötlus. Sina upload Id. Mingi monsterpildi. Nemad pakivad selle veits kokku, aga vahel nad ütlevad ka seda kui nad seda teevad. Vahel nad ei ütle. Vahel Nad annavad võimaluse. Google album
Õpetaja: Google Photos. Noh, Google Drive Share Ib Seda Space, Onju, Seal on samamoodi. Iga kord, kui te ta alguses hakkate, upload ima, siis ta juba küsib kohe ära, et kas sa tahad pildi kvaliteeti hoida?
Õpetaja: Noh, sul on suured failid. Sul Saab seal kiiremini otsa või? Oled Sa nõus, et me veits kompressime? Vaata, Noh, teate ikka. Seda. Vaata, Teed ilusa pildi telefonis. Mõtled, kuidas arvutisse saada? Noh, Facebook Messenger iseendale sõnum
Õpetaja: selle arvutist. Ee pildi lahti. Vaatad kuradi nagu mingi kole nagu Öö
Õpetaja: Siis on see, et ta lihtsalt. Ega nemad ei soovi ka hoida omal seal mingi oma andmetes ee, mingeid Monsterfaile sellepärast, et see Lihtsalt sööb nende space.
Õpetaja: No teil on kompressivad. Ära teevad selle pildi vaata ja siis nad teevad lõpus ka kuskil peavad andmed hoidma ühel Või teisel viisil. Nad ei pruugi olla mingi base. Kuuekümne neljas. Mingi muid lahendusi on ka. Aga see on üks võimalus.
Õpetaja: See on Üks Võimalus, mis meie kasutame, sobib ideaalselt, sest see sama base. Kuuskümmend neli sobib meile sinna.
Õpetaja: Ee. Kuigi tegelikult olime Baltidena siiski lõpuks ja me Kommenteerime,
Õpetaja: teeme edasi tagasi seda fookus fookust. Aga sõnum, mis Jasonist saadab ee niiöelda Brauserile pildi. Teeb Seda kuuekümne neljas sellepärast image element.
Õpetaja: Img See element. Vaata, meil siis toetab täpselt seda asja.
Õpetaja: Ma tegin. Ju ma Just Paningi praegult kogu selle asja siia niimoodi maha
Õpetaja: ja kui vaadata. Siis me näeme seda pilti.
Õpetaja: Siin. Sees on alates sellest kohast siit. Põhimõtteliselt see Siit
Õpetaja: see, kuni siia lõpuni on base kuuskümmend, neli Kodeeringus, pildi info.
Õpetaja: Jah,
Õpetaja: noh, aga see on lihtsalt. See on põhiline asi on see, et siit on koristatud ära absoluutselt kõik koledad, sümbolid Ja asjad
Õpetaja: see sama asi. Vaata, Jason võtab stringi vastu. Näiteks
Õpetaja: me ei taha mingeid nurgelisi. Sulge asju, mis meile ära on ju erinevad Failformaadid. Kuidas andmed kanda? Point, mis? See, mida ta üritab, nagu teha, on see, et ta teeb selle söödavaks kõikidele sõnumisaatjatele sisuliselt ilma et midagi kuskilt katki läheks.
Õpetaja: Paneme lihtsalt stringina. Numbrid, Suured väiksed tähed. Pane mulle selline string.
Õpetaja: Ja see on kokku pandud nagu mingi konkreetse algoritmiga, Mis tähendab, et kuhu iganes sina selle saadad, sina saad selle tegelikult originaalkujul taastada või mõnele teisele kujule viia, nii nagu vaja,
Õpetaja: saad sa Alati teha. Ja vastupidi,
Õpetaja: et Html is ta meile meeldib. Sellepärast Html sööb seda. See imidž element.
Õpetaja: Annan sinna sisse, See string, tema joonistab pildi.
Õpetaja: Noh, ja kvaliteeti asjad kõik on siis vastavalt sellele, nagu kas on mingi töötlus või asi? Vahel
Õpetaja: nüüd meile see sama image input Praegult kuuskümmend. Nelja. Näete, siin on Event Event, New Image Selected.
Õpetaja: Siin on üks muutaja nimi.
Õpetaja: Image Startup is. Kuuskümmend neli.
Õpetaja: Kui sina tuled, Valid oma arvutist mingisuguse pildi.
Õpetaja: See koodijupp siin. Põhimõtteliselt siin Kombonaad teeb sellest kuuekümne nelja ja saadab pärandile ja ongi kõik
Õpetaja: nüüd meil kõik, Mis meil on vaja teha? Vaata, proovime nagu seda siin. Hästi, kiirelt.
Õpetaja: Aa, nii, kellelt kui jõuan. Ma teen siia. Img, teine muutuja.
Õpetaja: Ee, Kõigepealt ma panen siia kuulaja üles. Kuulaja, Mis see vent on?
Õpetaja: Event copy.
Õpetaja: Kui tuleb image input ist event.
Õpetaja: Nii, siis ma ruttu teen, Tata blokki. See on hästi kiire image data.
Õpetaja: See ei ole ka seda, mis kohta ei pea tegema. Ma põhimõtteliselt loen ma hästi kiirelt Näitan, sest tund on kohe läbi.
Õpetaja: Pane need image Data on vaikimised. Ühistring on nii
Õpetaja: nii. Mina ütlen, et kui alt tuleb Event New Image Selected.
Õpetaja: Siis ma ütlen siin kiirkorras, et tee niimoodi et temal saab olema uus väärtus. Mis iganes tuleb alt Event,
Õpetaja: nii see täidab selle ära.
Õpetaja: Mina panen selle sama image data siia. Source I alla.
Õpetaja: Ee, Ütlen, et see tuleb muutujast
Õpetaja: ja mul peaks olema nüüd niimoodi Refresh I ka üheks ajaks.
Õpetaja: Mina valin pildi.
Õpetaja: Panin selle sama pildi.
Õpetaja: See pilt.
Õpetaja: See tuli alt Childistys image input.
Õpetaja: Püüdsin selle kinni, Panin Data bloki. Image Data selle sisu siia sisse. Mul on siin üks image.
Õpetaja: Data Source kasutab seda kuuskümmend neli voolas. Siia saite mõttest aru, midagi taolist. Nii, aga nüüd on. Ee, nagu aitab. Ee, homme on reede nädala lõpp. Saaks juba vaadata neid materjale läbi.
Õpetaja: Palun vaadake videosid. Palun, ee. Vaadake. Ee, Kõike, mida te jaksate väga ootab.